m
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur été france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 6 juillet le gouvernement castex a
désormais un nouveau visage une équipe
de seize ministres et de 14 ministres
délégués quelques surprises
huit nouveaux ministres font leur entrée
au gouvernement dont barbara pompili à
la transition écologique eric dupond
moretti est la justice roselyne bachelot
à la culture l'ancien ministre du budget
le sarkozyste gérald darmanin succède à
christophe castaner place beauvau le
royaume uni et l'union européenne ont
repoussé à demain la reprise de leurs
négociations visant à surmonter les
divergences importantes qui persiste sur
leur relation post break site le
calendrier devient de plus en plus
serrée pour éviter un odile risques et
économiquement situation préoccupante en
iran sur le plan de la crise du kobe 19
le bilan quotidien des décès n'a jamais
été aussi élevé 160 nouveaux décès en 24
heures portant à plus de onze mille sept
cent le bilan de l'épidémie les
autorités iraniennes sont critiqués pour
leur gestion de la crise le port du
masque devient obligatoire
[Musique]
le suspense a donc pris fin peu après
19h tout à l'heure le secrétaire général
de l'elysée alexis colère a dévoilé la
composition du gouvernement castex
bonsoir katia vous êtes en direct sur
place de l'elysée gouvernement qui est
donc maintenant connu il y à quelques
surprises
oui quelques surprises mais pas autant
qu'on aurait pu penser c'est un nouveau
gouvernement qui fait la part belle à la
parité avec des postes clés confié
également à des hommes politiques
anciennement de droite devenue re dlr ou
de l'ump alors concernant les ministres
qui est content qu'ils ont conservé leur
poste bruno le maire est toujours à
l'économie florence parly ministre des
armées jean michel blanquer réducation
olivier vers en santé il ya jean yves le
drian aux affaires étrangères est en
revanche il y à un jeu de chaises
musicales
concernant d'autres ministères le
ministre du trésor du travail a été
confiée à elisabeth bornes le ministre d
outre-mer à sébastien lecornu qui
étaient aux collectivités territoriales
l'agriculture et l'alimentation vont
revenir à julien de normandie qui se
trouvait au logement et amélie de
montchalin secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes devient ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique pour les surprise relative
dirons nous c'est au tour de barbara
pompili de devenir ministre la
transition écologique c'est un transfuge
d'europe écologie livre les verts
devenus l air eau m
disons qu'elle suit vraiment la ligne du
parti donc ce n'est pas un choc de
cultures comme à l'époque de nicolas
hulot
l' autre surprise celle de l'arrivée
la place beauvau de gérald darmanin ce
jeune homme de 37 ans qui passe du
budget à l'intérieur il a été a priori
préféré à jean michel blanquer rila
immédiatement tweeté que c'était un
honneur pour lui d'occuper ce poste en
tant que petit fils d'immigré il faisait
référence à son grand père
art qui il aura la lourde tâche de
restaurer la confiance de la police mais
aussi d'entendre les voix de ceux qui se
plaignent aujourd'hui des violences
policières
autre surprise roselyne bachelot sont
arrivés à la culture celle qui avait été
critiqué à l'époque de sa gestion de
l'épidémie d'épidémie pardon h1n1
lorsqu'elle était ministre de la santé
et bien revient en grâce aujourd'hui
elle est proche des milieux culturels il
faut dire que celle qui se dit une
vieille dame occupe depuis plusieurs
années des postes à la télé en tant que
chroniqueuse avec leur bachelot sur lci
ou encore chroniqueuse aux grosses têtes
et puis la grande surprise c'est
l'arrivée d'eric dupond moretti célèbre
pénaliste qui a été aussi bien l'avocat
d'abdelkader meira que de patrick
balkany ou encore bernard tapie
acquittator sow surnom lui déplaît mais
il montre bien que c'est un un avocat
extrêmement compétent qui a obtenu de
son 145e acquittement février 2020 en ce
moment il critique vertement le parquet
financier qui l'avait mis sur écoute
dans le cadre d'une affaire de
corruption qui impliquait possiblement
nicolas sarkozy pour retrouver une
présumée top de nicolas sarkozy donc le
torchon brûle
et il y aura sûrement des coups d'éclat
et il y a également une pléthore de
ministres délégués dont franck riester
qui a qui a pris à des fonctions de
chargé du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité emmanuelle wargon
ministre délégué chargé du logement
et quand marlène schiappa elle devient
ministre délégué de la citoyenneté dans
le cadre du ministère de l'intérieur
et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire à ses côtés
également françois boulot avocat et
gilet jaune bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être en direct sur rtl france
pour commenter donc se noue
au gouvernement castex qui a été dévoilé
aux alentours de 19h nos benedetti on
commence par vous d'une manière globale
que vous inspire ce gouvernement est ce
que vous même vous avez eu des surprises
ce soir
sur le fond c'est un gouvernement de
continuité ou on à président de la
république qui finalement poursuit la
ligne est la sienne qui évacuent un
certain nombre de ministres qui étaient
les ministres en difficulté je pense au
ministère l'intérieur je pense à la
porte avant le gouvernement je pense
dans la garde des sceaux et qui disons
sur le plan de la symbolique va chercher
quelques personnalités médiatiques qui
permettent finalement de faire oublier
la continuité de ce gouvernement et de
sa ligne politique vraisemblablement et
d'attirer là il des commentateurs s'est
récemment la plus grande surprise c'est
la nomination au poste de garde des
sceaux de monsieur dupont moretti
éventuellement un moindre degré celle de
madame bachelot à la culture quoique je
pense que très franchement c'est un
c'est un gouvernement qui encore une
fois ne traduit pas une rupture
fondamentale mais qui marque quand même
que emmanuel macron n'a pas réussi de
crise politique à gauche pratiquement
pas aucune et qui s'inscrit plutôt dans
une ligne que je qualifierais de
conservatrice parce qu'il sait que c'est
là qu'aujourd'hui résident
vraisemblablement sur l'espace pourny
françois boulot on va évidemment rentrée
a commenté justement ces nominations
tout cas pour les plus importants des
plus surprenantes à françois de boulot
dans son ensemble est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de ce nouveau gouvernement
bonsoir à tous je vais écouter je crois
que il faut déjà préciser qu'on commente
un événement on le sait puisque on
savait que les hommes à l'échangé
d'ailleurs pas surpris finalement voir
qu'il ya peu d'hommes qui ont changé en
réalité
mais quand bien même on les aurait tout
changé on change les hommes et pas la
politique c'est qu'en fait on fait le
mercato le transfert de ministres entre
portefeuille ici et là mais la politique
ne va pas changer et va pas changer
parce que enfin de penser que le pouvoir
se situerait entre les mains du
gouvernement on est en 5ème république
qui depuis le quinquennat et bien a
transmis tous les pouvoirs à un seul et
même homme
c'est le prix dont un public donc le
pouvoir était à l'elysée c'est la
réalité regardons les choses en face
donc emmanuel macron va continuer la
même politique
donc là c'est le changement dans la
continuité que comme l'a dit arnaud
benedetti et finalement il faut pas se
laisser abuser par ces changements de
casting qui est qu'ils n'en sont pas et
on essaie de faire des coûts de
communication mais ça va pas changer sur
le fond la politique et donc ça ne va
pas changer la vie des gens et je crois
qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens
aujourd'hui dans le pays qui sont
désabusés de ces artifices de
communication et qui aimeraient qu'on
résolve plutôt leurs problèmes plutôt
que le remède et des têtes de gondole en
affiche pourrait essayer de faire croire
aux gens qu'on est en train de faire
quelque chose pour alors nos bêtises
c'est vrai que emmanuel macron à nous
réveiller encore quelques jours ensemble
nous tracerons les contours de ce
nouveau chemin qui sera centré sur la
reconstruction économique social
environnemental et culturel de notre
pays on se souvient des discours d'
emmanuel macron juste après la crise du
coc vie de 19 un nouveau visage d'une
changement est ce que selon vous ce
gouvernement aujourd'hui est capable
d'un vrai tournant dans la politique du
président de la république est
extrêmement difficile de le dire à ce
stade mais en tout cas les indications
qui sont donnés par sa composition ne
préjuge pas d'un tour dont clairement
les hommes disent quelque part la
politique est là en l'occurrence on voit
qu'on est dans
encore une fois de continuité moi ce qui
me fera par contre c'est que finalement
le design communicants d' emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui est en quelque sorte
en rupture c'est qu' il ne peut même
plus en l'occurrence d'une certaine
manière faire fonctionner son en même
temps donc parce qu'il a tout simplement
compris que il avait vraisemblablement
brûlé la plupart de ces vaisseaux sur sa
gauche
donc il investit de manière subliminale
est même passée limina de manière assez
explicite un espace politique et celui
disons des conservateurs de la droite
orléaniste et on voit que la nomination
de monsieur castex qui remplace monsieur
philippe obéit à cette logique
il a vraisemblablement cris pacte qu' il
fallait arrimer un électorat
conservateur à son entreprise politique
pour pouvoir finalement créer les
conditions d'un renouvellement de son
mandat en 2022 il fait un pari politique
de ce point de vue là sera-t-il ce pari
entendu ça c'est une autre question
parce que sur le fond je rejoins ce qu
est ce qu a dit monsieur boulot sous le
fond les fracturations de la société
française sont très fortes et finalement
l'autonomie du politique est relative
en l'occurrence et les problèmes
auxquels il va être confronté auquel son
executive est confronté ne seront
certainement pas résolu par un cap alors
effectivement il fait le pari des
conservateurs
françois boulot mais on sait qu'il ya
des dossiers chauds qui attendent
emmanuel macron dès la rentrée
d'ailleurs à commencer par celui des
retraites qui avait mis pas mal de monde
dans la rue au sujet de ces retraites
monsieur castex notre nouveau premier
ministre a dit qu'il voulait les
relancer dès l'été plus urgent de ségur
de la santé également
est ce que justement cette se maintient
du côté de l conservatrice est ce que
c'est vraiment ce qu'il fallait
aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron pour
remonter justement cette cote de
popularité il ya deux prismes 1 à voir
si on situe sur quand la stratégie des
menus macron oui c'est plutôt une bonne
stratégie il a pour être réélu en 2022
parce qu'il a pour lui le soutien du
bloc bourgeois c'est la classe moyenne
supérieure
c'est l'ancienne classe qui a voté pour
la droite et on a vu lors des élections
européennes
alors qu'il avait eu des électeurs de
gauche une partie des électeurs de
gauche lors 2017
il ya eu une bascule et il a plutôt
capter les électeurs de droite lors des
élections européennes ont finalement on
est dans la dynamique qui se poursuit
aujourd'hui l'a bien compris qu'en vo il
avait beaucoup plus de chances d'être
élu par le bloc
à droite le bloc de droite le
conservateur traditionnel pour 2022 nous
sur deux conduit là c'est une bonne
stratégie électoraliste pour venir mâcon
mais après il ya l'autre point de vue en
fait le ccc celui qu'on peut avoir quand
on est un citoyen quand on est soucieux
de l'intérêt général
quand on est soucieux de l'avenir de
notre pays quand on est soucieux de
l'avenir des gens qui vivent dans ce
pays il ya toujours aujourd'hui 9
millions de pauvres dans notre pays un
essai le chiffre augmente d'année en
année il ya 150 milles ldf enfin on sait
que l'état du pays né est extrêmement
précaire fragile au beaucoup de
personnes et on sait que la catastrophe
économique arrive est d'ailleurs mma
qu'on l'a confirmé il va y avoir des
faillites qui vont continuer qui vont se
poursuivre et ça va être un cataclysme à
la rentrée dans ce cadre là la question
qui posait c est ce qu on fait comme
avant c'est à dire une politique qui a
conduit à la montée des inégalités et un
chômage de masse à une
désindustrialisation massive dans le
pays où est-ce qu'on change enfin de
politique le problème c'est que jean
castex
il a déjà donné des éléments de réponse
alors effectivement avec la question de
la réforme des retraites
il explique que il va essayer de la
faire passer très rapidement et dans les
termes sur les grands lignes qui seront
exactement les mêmes que la réforme dont
les sondages montraient qu'elle était
rejetée par quasiment deux tiers de
l'opinion publique t il s'est présenté
par ce qu on fait de la communication ne
change pas le fond s'est présenté comme
un gaulliste un gaulliste social
sauf qu'il n'est ni gaulliste ni sociale
cerc eux ils ne croient pas en l'état
parce que juste après avoir décrété
gaulliste social il expliqué que pour
l'état ne pouvait pas tout 1 qu'il
fallait en appelle à la responsabilité
individuelle de chacun bon bah ça c'est
la définition du libéralisme économique
donc c'est tout sauf gaulliste le
gaullisme c'est justement un état
extrêmement fort un état
interventionniste dans l'économie puis
par ailleurs il n'est pas social puisque
il a repris la ritournelle des libéraux
c'est à dire il faut d'abord produire la
richesse et ensuite la redistribuer
alors je conteste pas le principe mais
ce sont ces toujours derrière ce
principe que les libéraux se cachent
pour ne pas changer la clé de
répartition des richesses et donc ne pas
changer le régime fiscal applicable ne
pas lutter contre l'évasion fiscale bref
ne pas changer contre les règles qui
font que les ultra-riches de ce pays
capte très largement les richesses qui
sont produites
et alors qu'on a une richesse qui devra
aujourd'hui est donc être répartie
beaucoup plus équitablement
ce qui n'est pas 4 donc on va avoir la
même politique libérale et qui va
continuer à s'appliquer malheureusement
je vais vous faire écouter quelques
réactions les premières à la suite de ce
nouveau gouvernement
les annonces en tout cas de son nouveau
gouvernement écouter un gouvernement
libéral banal castaner belloubet honte
de l'intérieur et de la justice enfants
démissionner darmanin et dupond moretti
doivent rétablir la dignité et l'honneur
à la justice est nommé en militant
d'extrême gauche qui souhaite
l'interdiction du rassemblement national
premier parti d'opposition
ça promet si bête et castaner dehors
petit bonheur du soir
pour le reste on reprend largement les
mêmes et on recommence et je m'attends à
une belle pagaille à la justice avec
dupond moretti
de toute façon tous européiste donc zéro
changement possible les français
voulaient changer de politique et garder
le même premier ministre
emmanuel macron a fait exactement
l'inversé il charge le premier ministre
mais avec ce nouveau gouvernement
on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement politique est l'une des
réactions qu'on retiendra arnaud
benedetti celle de marine le pen
concernant eric dupond-moretti elle dit
de lui voilà on a mis finalement à la
justice d'un militant d'extrême gauche
qui voient supprimer le premier parti
d'opposition en france c'est-à-dire son
parti le rassemblement national est ce
que vous partagez ce diagnostic de
marine le pen
non je ne suis pas sûr que monsieur
dupont moretti veulent supprimer
le rassemblement national de le problème
de monsieur dupont moretti c'est que
d'abord c'est quelqu'un qui a énormément
de talent et chacun s'accorde à lui
reconnaître qu'il est un grand avocat
qu'il appartient cette tradition du
verbe des débris thouars qui est
incontestable la difficulté c'est que le
tempérament de monsieur dupont moretti
va-t-il pouvoir se mouvoir dans la
fonction de garde des sceaux on sait que
c'est quelqu'un de particulièrement
électif qui a des positions qui sont
parfois d'ailleurs justifié mais
extrêmement vivante
il va avoir à gérer également le corps
des magistrats
donc c'est extrêmement difficile pour un
ministre de la justice d'être dans une
situation qui risque d'être dans une
situation de le mettre dans une
situation conflictuelle
donc il y a indéniablement si vous
voulez de la part d' emmanuel macron la
volonté d'aller chercher quelqu'un dont
on reconnaît à la fois le charisme des
compétences et le talent mais qui est
vraisemblablement sera plutôt difficile
à gérer politiquement à contrôler
politiquement parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui lui a une grande autonomie
personnelle et qui vraisemblablement ne
se laissera pas dicter sa conduite donc
il y a au delà du coup de com' plutôt
réussie en l'occurrence une zone de
risque pour le président de la
république et pour le premier ministre
en désignant monsieur du bonbon et y à
la chancellerie
voilà pour eric dupond-moretti autres
nominations qui attire l'attention
évidemment celle de gérald darmanin à
l'intérieur à la place de christophe
castaner françois boulot vous l'avocat
des gilet jaune on sait que christophe
castaner a été beaucoup critiqué pour sa
gestion des manifestations évidemment le
préfet l'allemand encore plus à paris
mais avec les ordres du ministre est ce
que c'est une bonne chose pour vous ce
remplacement par le sarkozyste gérald
darmanin
je crois que rien ne va changer et
darmana il était déjà au gouvernement
et puis par ailleurs qu'à scanner ne
faisait qu'appliquer les consignes des
manuels macron encore une fois c'est à
dire que vous avez un pouvoir qui mène
une politique qui la mène de façon
brutale il brutalise les gens parce que
la plupart des réformes qui ont posé
problème a été rejetée majoritairement
dans le pays emmanuel macron n'en a que
faire
il y passe en force et pour ça eh bien
il a besoin de la police effectivement
d'instrumentaliser la police parce qu'on
l'a vu il ya eu les gilet jaune
évidemment il ya eu la grève contre la
réforme des retraites
bref il ya eu des mouvements de
contestation extrêmement important et
qu'il a fallu canaliser qu'angers
canaliser en fait il a fallu brutaliser
les citoyens dans les manifestations les
mettre en garde à vue prononcer des
condamnations judiciaires etc bref c'est
une stratégie du pouvoir une stratégie
qui est d'y piloter dirigé par emmanuel
macron donc darmanin castaner ou un
autre ça ne va rien changer voyez je ne
crois pas que gérald darmanin
il a un grand projet en tant que miss de
l'intérieur de réformer par exemple igpn
un brillé alors que pourtant on sait
très bien que c'est un organisme mais
aussi dans beaucoup de dossiers travail
plutôt à nettoyer les preuves à ne pas
écouter les témoin qui serait pourtant
déterminant dans telle ou telle affaire
de violences policières
donc non gérald darmanin ça ne va rien
changer
quant à eric dupond moretti et même si
je garde un devoir de réserve évidemment
parce que il ya une heure ou deux il
était encore l'an des confrères sur plan
déontologique la courtoisie commande
qu'on compte cette critique paul
mais je suis très curieux de voir quelle
position il va prendre
premièrement par là par rapport à la
réforme des retraites parce que cette
réforme elle va impacter très fortement
les cabinets d'avocats et notamment les
petits cabinets d'avocats dont beaucoup
risquent de mourir
tout simplement à cause de cette réforme
des retraites parce que le taux de
cotisation va exploser dans le cas de
cette réforme
ensuite je suis curieux de voir sa
position sur l'indépendance de la
justice parce qu'on a vu effectivement
notamment les pressions qui ont été
exercées par les la magistrate du
parquet national financiers sur ces
magistrats subordonnés et puis également
évidemment sa position sur l'aspect
d'une liberté fondamentale puisque on a
vu qu'il ait pris position notamment sur
les écoutes téléphoniques bon bref on va
voir tout ça je suis curieux parce que
j'ai l'impression que il met les pieds
dans un cadre soit qu'il n'a pas compris
mais soit dont ils ne voient pas les
conséquences
mais en tout état de cause je ne vois
pas un seul instant
emmanuel macron lui donner carte blanche
pour réformer la justice dans un sens
plus respectueux des libertés
emmanuel macron a fait la preuve nous
tout le contraire qui au final en les le
respect des libertés individuelles
salut importé peu et on a vu que ces
libertés ont été bafoués dans le cadre
du mouvement de gilet jaune
merci françois volant on va vous
remercier arnaud benedetti vous restez
avec nous on va accueillir dans quelques
instants didier maïsto président de sud
radio mais avant cela je vous propose de
regarder un petit résumé de ce qu'il
faut retenir de cette annonce du nouveau
gouvernement
castex
[Musique]
on
et on accueille avec nous au didier
maïsto président de sud radio qui nous a
rejoint au côté d'arnaud benedetti pour
commenter ce nouveau gouvernement didier
macho qu'est-ce qu'il vous inspire elle
vous inspire cette équipe castex bonsoir
alors je pense qu'on est passé du
nouveau monde à un casting de télé
réalité en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
monsieur mâcon a mandaté un mandaté son
premier ministre pour lui dire tu me
fais de la place je veux pas être embêté
en 2022 et donc c'est un gouvernement
très politicien cette politique tournée
vers l'ambition présidentielle
d'emmanuel mâcon ça n'aura échappé à
personne et pas du tout tourné vers les
français
quand vous voyez c'est des prises à
médiatique comme achiou qui fait des
émissions de télé sur une chaîne humaine
stream
eric dupont maire de meaux est il tout
le monde s'accorde à dire qu'à
talentueux mais enfin c'est surtout
depuis longtemps le nomme médiatique
monsieur argana qui a fait le caprice
qui a menacé de quitter le gouvernement
ce n'était pas promu il a été entendu
pourquoi proche de xavier bertrand
il permet de neutraliser cette droite
puisque on voit bien aujourd'hui que le
le barycentre les qui vibre de monsieur
m'a conquis du tout avec la gauche
complètement dans cette droite 63
bourgeois comme ça a été dit hey hey hey
hey un peu moins c'est un peu le ventre
mou la démocratie n ya en fait ils
neutralisent c'est très politique il
neutralise les possibles des potentiels
d'adversaires vous vous rendez compte on
est passé du nouveau monde
après une crise comme eux comme on a
connu avec le call it sans précédent à
l'échelle mondiale où on a rappelé que
l'une plans sociaux allaient se succéder
ou les faillites déjà succèdent où on
nous parle sans arrêt des colonies vous
avez un gouvernement où il n'y a pas
beaucoup de changements et où
l'essentiel des prises sont des gens qui
ne feront pas non
ils ont fait allégeance dès le début que
ce soit europe ecologie les verts ou les
républicains où le parti socialiste
des gens qui ont vu les yeux de chimène
pour emmanuel patron donc il a promu ces
gens là le pas il veut pas leur
d'embêtements
pour la poésie de la présidentielle 2022
je crois que tout le monde ait accompli
sans être grand clerc
arnaud benedetti peu de grosses prises à
gonchar pesc de grosses prises du côté
des élèves tout même mais on fait
beaucoup les sarkozystes dans ce
gouvernement
oui vraisemblablement parce que si vous
voulez on a glissé de la droite du pays
est que qu'incarner le précédent que les
ministres edouard philippe à une droite
plutôt sarkozyste mais aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron a parfaitement compris
que si il voulait conserver une chance
d'être réélu en 2022
il fallait qu'il arriva est arrimée
encore une fois cet électorat de
centre-droit ou de droite qui considère
que peut-être il constituera le meilleur
rempart face à une gauche qui
reviendrait d'une certaine manière avec
parfois quelques formes de radicalité
la stratégie d'eads emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui c'est de toute façon une
stratégie de design politique tout ce
qui a été fait lors de ce remaniement
vise tout simplement à créer un effet de
communication qui va alimenter pendant
quelques jours les commentaires les
éditorialistes mais qui sur le fond ne
constitue pas véritablement encore une
fois un changement de ligne politique
il y a eu dans l'histoire de la vème
république des changement de premier
ministre
cotillons qui ont correspondu avec des
changements de ligne politique
là en l'occurrence eux on est dans
lyon d'un changement de ligne politique
et les prises en effet je rejoins ce
qu'a dit didier maïsto les prises
médiatique d'un certain nombre de
personnalités jouent quelque part un
rôle de leurs communicants pour
alimenter la chronique politique mais
sur le fond ses sets sont néfastes
disons à quelque chose qui ne correspond
même pas un événement politique
on est face à disons une extension
supplémentaire dans la communication
politique alors arrivé numéro deux en or
la liste du gouvernement dévoilés par
alexis colère tout à l'heure sur les
marches de l'elysée barbara pompili ans
était évidemment un poste extrêmement
attendu après le succès des verts au
municipal lorsque barbara pompili et de
nature justement à promouvoir un petit
peu plus l'écologie on sait que ça n'a
pas été le fort des manuels macron
pendant la première partie de son
quinquennat
didier maïsto en tout cas elle est déjà
prévu sa propre candidature et elle a
déjà au mieux emmanuel macron dès le
début ça me fait penser qu'ils en
prenant son sang en sang à tes rêves
irrévérencieux vous savez mr le
president happy busday pomper dit
pompidou bon bah voilà finalement tout
ça n'a pas beaucoup d'importance
ce sont des gens comme le comme si vous
regardez un peu tout ce gouvernement qui
ont fait très rapidement les yeux doux à
-b dual macro et on voit bien tourner
comme le sud j'ai rejoint alain obesity
sur cette histoire de design politique
on voit bien que les partis politiques
ne correspond plus du tout à la tente
des français qu'on fait du marketing
alors ce pas un petit peu envers un
petit peu en veux un petit peu en rose
mais finalement on a comme ça on se
retrouve sur l'essentiel l'essentiel
étant la promotion de sa carrière de sa
propre carrière en faisant la promotion
du président la république ce qu'elle
voit ce que au delà de ces aspects un
peu rocambolesques et un peu finalement
superfétatoire qui n'intéressent pas
voulait france et j'attends de voir
comment eric dupond moretti va être
accueilli par les magistrats il a eu des
mots très durs vis-à-vis des magistrats
choisir quelqu'un comme ça qui remet en
cause sans cesse l'indépendance des
juges auraient sans doute parfois à
raison mais c'est quand même
un petit peu surprenant et on a
l'impression que c'est un peu aussi un
gouvernement non pas des grosses têtes
puisque madame bachelot était
pensionnaire des grosses têtes mais plus
de grandes gueules pour reprendre le nom
d'une émission aussi assez connue donc
il suffit aujourd'hui
finalement si j'ai aussi jaurès dans la
politique partisane de trahir son camp
de le trahir le plus vite possible et en
hurlant le plus fort et vous êtes
récompensé par un poste de ministre
finalement c'est le pire de l'ancien
monde imaginé qu'il y encore quelques
mois
ces gens-là voulait révolutionner la
france sans parler des start up nation
on parlait de réinventer la politique
monsieur mâcon a écrit un livre pratique
l évolution et la révolution il en fait
se re mêmes qui sont partis de la droite
en passant par le sang en passant par la
gauche et ils sont revenus
merci des brestois merci deuxième tome
ercis également arnaud benedetti nous
avons accompagné pour réagir à cette
annonce un du nouveau gouvernement une
équipe de seize ministres de 14
ministres délégués quelques surprises
on l'a vu on y reviendra évidemment dans
notre édition de 21h en direct sur rt
france est 20h30 soyez les bienvenus
simon ou rejoignez dans l'actualité
également à situation très préoccupante
nous sommes un petit problème de
compteurs pardonnez-moi la reprise des
négociations sur le break sites qui ont
été repoussées demain à londres le
royaume uni et l'union européenne peine
encore à définir leurs futures relations
commerciales et économiques
les discussions ont été compliqués à
bruxelles toute la semaine le
négociateur européen michel barnier a
évoqué de sérieuses divergences
son homologue britannique david frost a
quant à lui souligné à des différences
significatives
la date butoir pour ces négociations
prendra fin le 31 décembre mais les
européens souhaitent un accord pour
octobre risque d'un mode il pourrait
bien être dévastateur pour d économie
déjà fragilisée par la pandémie de
coronavirus et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec claude
blanchemaison soyez bienvenue au club
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
michel barnier un qui est donc arrivé à
londres pour une semaine ce lundi alors
que les négociations sur un accord
commercial patine clairement dans quel
état d'esprit se trouve le négociateur
en chef de l'union européenne michel
barnier est très déterminé que comme
toujours
d'abord il a un mandat un mandat très
clair du conseil c'est à dire des états
membres il rend compte à la présidente
de la commission
ursula von der leyen et le compte sur
cette position européenne qui comporte
trois éléments comme vous le savez le
premier c'est que pour avoir un libre
accès au marché unique au marché
intérieur européen
eh bien il faut que les britanniques
promettre de s'ajuster aux conditions de
concurrence européennes c'est à dire
qu'on veut éviter que l'économie
britannique
sa franchise de contraintes
environnementales sociales voire même
fiscal et créer une sorte de singapour
sur la tamise
en deuxième lieu on veut que les droits
historiques d'épaisseur de deux pêcheurs
européens soient respectées dans les
eaux britanniques et en troisième lieu
que lorsque les différends commerciaux
mettent en jeu
interprétation du rang européen et bien
ce soit la cour de justice des
communautés européennes qui tranche et
sur ces trois points les britanniques
sont en désaccord absolue et britannique
dont ceux d'ici beaucoup trop compliqué
faisons un accord de libre-échange pure
et simple
faisons le rapidement signé tout de
suite et d'ailleurs il faut le faire
avant la fin du mois de juillet
autrement dit une négociation à la
hussarde pour les britanniques dans
lequels on entreprend dans les détails
ce n'est pas la conception de l'union
européenne et les britanniques le savent
bien puisqu'ils sont dans l'union
européenne depuis 47 ans alors pouvez
vous nous citer les principaux points de
blocage
eh bien oui c'est point de blocage c'est
d'abord la conception générale pour les
britanniques donc une zone de libre
échange et d'ailleurs se sont ils ont
ils ont toujours été favorable à un
libre échange pure et simple puisque en
1960 ils ont créé une association
européenne de libre échange qui voulait
contrer le marché commun naissant
l'ancêtre de l'union européenne la
plupart des pays nordiques se sont
associés à ces à l'époque au britannique
jusqu'à ce que les uns et les autres
considèrent que l'union européenne était
sans doute plus intéressante et qui tu
l'avais le pour négocier leur entrée
dans l'union européenne
alors je ne pense pas qu'aujourd'hui les
britanniques cherchent à retrouver la
zone européenne de libre échange mais ça
y ressemble un petit peu et
effectivement je crois qu'ils veulent
surtout affirmer leur souveraineté
par conséquent pas d'intervention de la
cour européenne de justice pas de pêche
des pêcheurs européens continentaux dans
les eaux britanniques sauf accord
bilatéral à conclure chaque année avec
chacun des pays et par ailleurs ils ne
veulent pas s'engager à respecter des
conditions de concurrence européenne que
ce soit en matière d'environnement en
matière sociale ou en matière fiscale
donc il ya du pain sur la planche et
effectivement le la position européenne
et qu'il faut négocier qu'il faut
prendre le temps de négocier au moins
jusqu'au mois d'octobre alors sur quelle
s p des négociations seront elles centre
est précisément cette semaine
cette semaine je crois qu'on va aborder
les points techniques que je viens
d'évoquer
évidemment le sujet principal pour les
britanniques c'est l'accès au marché
unique
ils veulent pouvoir accéder à ce marché
de 450 millions de consommateurs qui est
un marché avec un fort pouvoir d'achat
et ils veulent pouvoir y accéder sans
payer des droits de douane sans avoir un
statut de pays tiers
par conséquent les conditions qui sont
mises par l'union européenne
eh bien ce sont les conditions de
respect encore une fois des conditions
de concurrence avec l'appréciation à
chaque fois de l'évolution des
conditions de concurrence et
naturellement les britanniques ne
veulent pas s'engager à s'aligner sur la
réglementation européenne au cours des
années prochaines cours des années
futures
donc ça va être un point majeur je crois
que la pêche qui intéresse beaucoup la
france la belgique et l'allemagne sera
aussi un autre point majeur parce qu'il
s'agit là de la souveraineté sur les
eaux territoriales britanniques
de la même façon que la compétence de la
cour de justice des communautés
européennes alors ces négociations au
club blanchemaison elle selon vous des
chances d'aboutir à un accord
la chancelière angela merkel qui s'y
connaît a dit la semaine dernière
il faut se préparer à l'hypothèse d'un
odile à leur deal or no deal comme on
dit à londres
effectivement les deux hypothèses
existent sur la table les britanniques
comme je laisse tout à l'heure veulent
une négociation très rapide donc sans
négocier sur les détails techniques
or tous tout cela dans l'union
européenne est fait de naturellement de
détails techniques et l'union européenne
avec monsieur barnier comme négociateur
ne peut pas brader ses positions donc en
effet il ya un risque de nos deals à la
fin de l'année et dans ce cas là eh bien
ce sera des conditions seront sans doute
assez difficile pour la grande bretagne
la grande bretagne veut d'ailleurs
négocier les accords de libre échange
avec les pays du monde entier qui
voudront bien à négocier des accords de
libre échange avec elle-même elle compte
beaucoup sur les relations qu'elle
allait relation particulière qu'elle a
avec le canada
et avec d'autres pays du commonwealth
pour négocier des accords de libre
échange
monsieur trump lui même a promis un
accord de libre échange à la grande
bretagne qui soit formidable comme il
l'a dit mais on peut lui faire confiance
pour que l'accord que les américains
pourrait octroyer à la grande bretagne
sera un accord au profit de l'économie
américaine america first et qui ne devra
nullement accès aux marchés publics
américains alors on qu'un peu d'enjeu
maison de nos deals quelles seraient les
règles qui s'appliquerait aux échanges
commerciaux entre lieux et le royaume
uni alors les britanniques naturellement
ont déjà pris les mesures qui
s'imposaient c'est à dire qu'ils ont
fabriqué un tarif douanier il n'existait
pas puisqu'il appliquer le tarif
douanier commun de l'union européenne
donc à partir du moment où ils seront en
dehors de l'union européenne le 1er
janvier prochain
s'il n'y a pas de deal s'il n'y a pas un
accord de coopération et du libre
échange et bien ils appliqueront leurs
nouveaux tarifs douaniers elles
reconnaissent par les douaniers il est
les tarifs sont très faibles sur les
sujets pour lesquels les britanniques
ont besoin d'importer notamment en
matière agroalimentaire mais il est
protecteur
là où les britanniques contre une
industrie à protéger par exemple en
matière automobile et dans d'autres
sujets également pour lesquels il existe
une industrie presse britannique
et puis l'union européenne elle un tarif
douanier commun qu'elle appliquera
également qu'elle appliquera en
marchandises britannique
ça sera un changement considérable avec
des complications extrêmes notamment
pour éviter qu'une frontières douanières
ne s'instaure directement ou
indirectement entre l'irlande du nord
qui fait partie du royaume uni et la
république d'irlande qui est là bien sûr
reste à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
d'ailleurs ça sera probablement un des
enjeux majeurs de la fin de cette
négociation et c'est pour ça que les
britanniques pensent que l'union
européenne n'osera pas porter la
responsabilité d'un odile parce qu'on
sait bien que cela mettrait en jeu
peut-être même l'unité du royaume uni
dans la mesure où les irlandais d'une
heure
ne peuvent pas accepter qu'il y ait une
frontière physique avec la république
d'irlande dans la mesure où les écossais
et les gallois ont également voté contre
le rexy probablement se manifesteront et
le s'opposeront à londres sur un certain
nombre de sujets alors toujours dans la
perspective d'un odile quelles seraient
les conséquences économiques et
politiques pour les deux parties je
pense que les conséquences économiques
seront assez sérieuse
bien sûr personne ne le souhaite et du
côté européen dit du côté des acteurs
économiques britanniques un odile mais
boris johnson prend elle a adopté une
tactique qui risque fort d'y aboutir
donc en effet il y aura des conséquences
sans doute pour un certain nombre de
secteurs britannique qui subiront les
conséquences puisque les britanniques
bien sûr on la majorité de leurs
échanges économiques avec le continent
européen et pas avec d'autres
partenaires plus ou moins chimérique
pour ce qui est des états membres de
l'union européenne
il y aura aussi des conséquences puisque
pour beaucoup de deux produits une
partie est fabriqué dans 20 états une
autre partie fabriqué un autre état
c'est vrai même pour les avions c'est
vrai même pour airbus et que on se
trouvera dans des difficultés techniques
considérables pour faire circuler ses
parties de construction d'avions ou même
de construction d'automobiles ou
d'autres produits d'un pays à l'autre à
travers les droits de douane
alors est-ce aussi la question majeure
qui est quid de la city c'est à dire de
la place financière de londres
et là dans le fond c'est les banques qui
vont décider ce sont les institutions
financières qui vont décider est-ce
qu'elles auront plus de liberté en
restantes à londres est ce qu elles
s'installeront sur le continent je pense
qu'elles feront les deux en réalité et
qu'elles joueront en effet sur la paie
leurs possibilités d'arbitrage entre la
législation britannique et la
législation européenne
alors cela dit pour quand même donné une
note optimiste vous avez dit en débutant
que
la semaine dernière les négociations
avaient été assez raide à bruxelles
mais curieusement la livre sterling a
monté la semaine dernière ce qui prouve
que les principaux acteurs économiques
considèrent que l'eau nous lille n'est
pas une fatalité et que peut-être des
choses ont commencé à bouger pour aller
vers une véritable négociation
merci beaucoup au clos de blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse et on en vient à cette
situation préoccupante en iran sur le
front de la crise du coc vide 19 le
bilan quotidien des décès n'a jamais été
aussi élevé 163 24 heures le port du
masque est donc désormais obligatoire
dans certains lieux publics ouverts
notamment dans les transports en commun
écouter ce qu'on pense une partie de la
population iranienne
si les citoyens n'utilise pas de masque
nous ne les laisserons pas entrer dans
le métro de plus la police du métro il
est également stationnée dans nos
terminaux nous avons déployé nos force
exécutive
naturellement nous ne permettrons pas à
ceux qui n'ont pas de masque de monter
dans le bus comme je les dis j'ai visité
quelques autobus et dans certains à un
ou deux passagers n'avaient pas de
masque nous les avons donc sortis des
véhicules à partir d'aujourd'hui le port
du masque est obligatoire à travers le
pays
j'ai donc ajuster le dossier du siège en
conséquence je transporte de passagers à
l'arrière et je demande aux passagers de
porter un masque pour monter dans le
taxi
à mon avis ces ordres aurait dû être
donnée plus tôt il aurait dû rendre
obligatoire le port du masque afin que
nous ne perdions pas nos chers
compatriotes dans ces circonstances
difficiles à voir un masque est devenu
obligatoire à partir de maintenant
cela signifie pour moi que quiconque qui
ne porte pas de masque ne favorise pas
sa santé et celle de ses compatriotes
j'ai fait une erreur car je ne le porte
pas cela est vraiment une action
opportune parce que ne pas porter un
masque nous incite à propager le virus
et à le transmettre à beaucoup de gens
ou à être infecté nous-mêmes ne pas
porter un masque est une trahison et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec marc naze shir ali sociologue
franco iranienne enseignante à sciences
po bonsoir marnaise chez ali merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord peut-on évaluer l'ampleur
de la pandémie en iran il est très
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe au
niveau la situation iranienne est très
confuse dans le sens où l'état a décidé
de ne pas dévoiler le chiffre exact des
morts et des victimes
alors dans cette situation quand il y à
une décision étatique comme quoi il faut
pas être dévoilé le chiffre exact vous
pouvez imaginer à quel point on est dans
la confusion
on ne sait pas très bien ce qui se passe
et ce n'est pas d'ailleurs la première
fois que je précise que la république
islamique ne dévoile pas le chiffre des
victimes
on sait que après six mois on ne sait
pas encore combien de morts combien de
victimes on a eu au mois de novembre
alors que reuters dévoilé le chiffre de
1500 personnes
l'état iranien refuse encore de dévoiler
le chiffre exact
la même stratégie pour le coronavirus
après plusieurs mois
on ne sait pas exactement ce qui se
passe dans ce pays on ne sait pas encore
combien de victimes
les seules informations que nous avons
pu obtenir était de la part des médecins
qui ont regroupé
les statistiques des différents hôpitaux
ce qu'on a connu ce qu'on a pu
comprendre est extrêmement alarmants
dans le sens où on est en face d'un cas
médicalement atypique dans le sens où
les victimes pour la plupart sont très
très jeune
l'iran est le seul pays pour l'instant
où les morts de coronavirus ont 100 kg
maximum de 30 ans donc une population
d'entre 20 et comptant est victime de
covile 19
donc c'est un cas atypique alors on sait
évidemment vous venez de le décrire la
situation est grave même si on n'en
connaît pas l'ampleur et l'importance on
peut se demander pourquoi l'iran est-il
le pays le plus touché du proche et du
moyen-orient aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a
un début d'explication
écoutez c'est très simple parce que
c'est le pays en ce moment qui est sous
les sanctions c'est le pays où
l'économie est complètement paralysé
déjà depuis 40 ans la mauvaise gestion
du pays ont conclu qu a complètement
paralysé l'économie
les dernières années l'économie
iranienne était moribonde à la cause des
sanctions cette économie est encore plus
malade et donc fonctionne plus ses
tournées en face d'une population
quasiment affamés la mauvaise nutrition
a fait baisser la défense immunitaire de
la population c'est pourquoi même les
jeunes de 30 ans ne parviennent pas
résister au virus
la stratégie mise en place par le
pouvoir central est particulièrement
critiquée elle aussi à tort à raison
selon vous écoutez pas de toute façon on
est con critique jamais assez la
république islamique parce que il a
complètement laissé tomber la gestion de
pays
le pays est vraiment quand on écoute les
iraniens à moi je ça fait quand même des
années que je fais mes enquêtes à
travers les réseaux sociaux si
systématisme en contact avec les jeunes
les iraniens disent en fait qu' on n'a
pas un gouvernement on n'a pas les
hommes politiques on n'a pas des
responsables politiques qui s'occupent
d'eux
problèmes intérieurs c'est pourquoi
quand il y a virus comme corona qui
arrivent dans le pays la plupart d'entre
eux sont les réseaux sociaux on les
entend bilgi ce que m'a finalement le
coc vide est devenue la complice du
régime avant c'était le régime lui-même
qui nous tuait et la maintenance est la
maladie donc voilà et ils sont dans une
situation totalement désespérée et ils
ne savent pas du tout sortis ils peuvent
compter alors les états unis on le sait
continuer à mettre la pression sur
l'iran quelle peut être la position de
la communauté internationale pour venir
en aide aux pays qui vous venait
d'expliquer souffre économiquement et
maintenant sur cette question importante
de santé publique
et quelle que soit la situation de la
santé publique ce qui est catastrophique
en ce moment quelle que soit la
situation ce qui est évident qu'il ya
une grande partie je dirais pas tous les
iraniens mais grande partie de la
population iranienne sont contre ce
régime reclus de la république islamique
parce qu'après 41 ans
ce régime a montré son incapacité pour
gérer ce pays
il a mis en fait le pays à feu et à sang
ça fait plus de deux mois que les forêts
iraniennes sont en feu ça fait un moment
que les installations iraniens sont
prêts le feu les unes après les autres
donc vraiment le pays est complètement
délabré alors dans cette situation la
seule solution que la plupart des
iraniens comptent je peux entendre à
travers leurs commentaires à travers
leur souhait c'est que les européens
arrête de soutenir la république
islamique et laisser ce régime partir et
que les iraniens finalement arrive à
gérer leur pays par eux mêmes et que ces
mots là ils ont montré qu'en même après
41 alors qu'ils sont incapables de gérer
ce pays
alors basta fini arrêter de soutenir la
république islamique
s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup marnage
sheikh ali d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
et sachez que l'inde est désormais le
troisième pays du monde le plus touché
par le comité
derrière les états unis et le brésil le
pays connaît ces derniers temps une
explosion du nombre de contaminations
près de sept cent mille personnes ont
été testées positives dans le pays
les détails avec clémence pital à
l'entrée de ce marché aux légumes de new
delhi un employé prend systématiquement
la température de chaque client venu
faire ses courses
les gestes barrières et les mesures
sanitaires semblent être respectée dans
ce quartier de la capitale indienne
pourtant le ministère de la santé a
rapporté une nouvelle hausse quotidienne
alarmante par rapport à ces dernières
semaines le virus circule en effet
rapidement dans les villes très
densément peuplés dont new delhi nous
avons peur mais nous devons quand même
surmonté ce réflexe chacun dans le monde
craint pour sa vie mais c'est aussi
nécessaire de travailler
la sensibilisation est nécessaire elle
permettrait de contrôler la propagation
du virus
le gouvernement craint qu'un demi
million de personnes ne soient
contaminés d'ici la fin du mois de
juillet certains états du sous continent
indien en pleine phase de déconfinement
envisage de prolonger des mesures
strictes dans certaines villes du pays
ici à bombay des personnels de santé
font du porte à porte à la recherche de
personnes présentant des symptômes du
virus
nous terminons si quelqu'un est
susceptible d'être contaminées ou non
c'est ce que nous faisons nous vérifions
leur température avec notre thermomètre
électronique et leur capacité
respiratoire avec la troc si m les
mesures de confinement instauré en 1
depuis fin mars ont été progressivement
levées les écoles métro cinémas et
salles de sport reste cependant ferme et
les vols internationaux sont toujours
cloués au sol le premier ministre
narendra modi a déclaré la semaine
dernière que le taux de mortalité était
sous contrôle mais que le pays traverse
est toujours un moment critique avec ton
dans quelques instants à nous
reviendrons sur la présentation du
troisième gouvernement du mandat d'
emmanuel macron et puis nous parlerons
d'une candidature surprise est là
l'élection présidentielle américaine
celle du rappeur kanye west
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck fait que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
ses cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu
que c'était bien que difficiles qui
avait une équipe de 25 usines et autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'offrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le comte d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ben ça m'a
rendu plus intolérant alors parfois elle
s'était d'ailleurs vous délirez autour
d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde avant
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité
l'égalité des chances pour tous
[Musique]
m
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on me vois pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre c'est très
industrialisé à sion cela ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différente qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail de dessin un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encouragea fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fonds pouvant remettre en cause la
pensée des groupes de pression pouvoir
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
active dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique des technocrates les
activistes et de nombreux journalistes
ne s'intéressent qu'à la partie qui va
dans leur sens et censure ou dévalorise
le reste fonds décide de ce que le
peuple doit penser
[Musique]
non
il
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 6 juillet le gouvernement castex a
désormais un visage une équipe de seize
ministres et de 14 ministres délégués
quelques surprises
huit nouveaux ministres font leur entrée
au gouvernement dont barbara puis il dit
à la transition écologique
eric dupond moretti à la justice
roselyne bachelot à la culture
l'ancien ministre du budget le
sarkozyste gérald darmanin succède à
christophe castaner place beauvau son
annonce a pris de court les spécialistes
de la politique américaine le rappeur et
homme d'affaires kanye west annoncé hier
sur les réseaux sociaux sa candidature
pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle américaine en novembre
le milliardaire et industriels elon
masque lui apporte son soutien
[Musique]
le suspense a donc pris fin peu après
19h tout à l'heure le secrétaire général
de l'elysée alexis colère a dévoilé la
composition du gouvernement castex ont
fait le point avec notre reporter katia
pique nique devant le palais de l'elysée
ce nouveau gouvernement ne s'illustre
pas par son effet de surprise mais
plutôt par une parité homme-femme et
l'accession à des postes clés
d'anciennes figures de la droite alors
concernant les ministres qui ont gardé
leur poste bruno le maire reste à bercy
florence parly reste ministre des armées
jean michel blanquer
reste à l'éducation libérant à la santé
en revanche au niveau des chaises
musicales et elisabeth borne basse du
transport au travail du lin de normandie
par exemple du logement à l'agriculture
la première semi surprise c'est
l'accession de barbara pompili au poste
de ministre de la transition écologique
c'est une ancienne transfuge d'europe
écologie les verts passés chez rml suis
vraiment la ligne du parti donc il n'y
aura pas de choc de cultures comme avec
nicolas hulot est d'ores et déjà les
voix écologistes s'élèvent contre ce
choix
les surprises maintenant il s'agit de
l'arrivée de gérald darmanin la place
beauvau ce jeune homme de 37 ans a été
préférée et donc à jean michel blanquer
rhin qui devait être pressenti il aura
la lourde tâche de regagner la confiance
de la police c'était un ministère qui
était sous le feu des critiques à cause
de la gestion de christophe castaner
alors une petite précision au titre des
polémiques il faut quand même dire que
gérald darmanin est actuellement sous le
coup d'une enquête judiciaire
une autre surprise la nomination de
roselyne bachelot
cet ancien ministre de la santé avait
quitté la politique pour devenir
chroniqueuse télé
eh bien elle devient ministre de la
culture la plus grande surprise ce
nouveau gouvernement c'est eric dupond
moretti
nommé en tant que garde des sceaux ce
célèbre avocat pénaliste surnommé
aquitator à sobriquet qu'il n'aime pas
mais qui rappelle sa compétence pour
faire acquitter ses clients c'était le
défenseur notamment de patrick balkany
bernard tapie encore à des le cadet
remera il faut noter dans son actualité
les traits
en colère contre le parquet financier en
effet celui-ci l'a fait mettre sur
écoute dans une affaire de corruption
impliquant nicolas sarkozy sinon une
pléthore de poste de ministre délégué a
été créée donc on y retrouve franck
riester recaser de la culture au
commerce extérieur et marlène schiappa
qui devient délégué à la citoyenneté
dans le cadre de ministère de
l'intérieur il faut aussi ajouter que
gabriella talent a été nommé en tant que
porte parole du gouvernement et remplace
ainsi si bête ndiaye et pour réagir à ce
mauvais gouvernement nous sommes avec
sébastien huyghe député et l'air du nord
benjamin avoir également professeur
d'histoire adhérents de la cgt du val de
marne bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
on commence par vous sébastien huyghe
vous devez être un homme plutôt heureux
ce soir vous le sarkozyste un ancien
porte parole du temps de nicolas sarkozy
c'est plutôt un gouvernement
conservateur proche des sarkozystes avec
nominé notamment la nomination de gérard
darmana oui enfin moi je trouve que
c'est surtout un un jeu de chaises
musicales où la plupart était ministre
dans le gouvernement précédent ils ont
juste changé de fonction donc on a
changé les étiquettes et puis on a
changé les chaises et puis à côté de ça
on a plutôt un casting people et donc
j'ai le sentiment plutôt qu'on va aller
vers un gouvernement qui sera à peu dans
la continuité de ce qu'a fait emmanuel
macron jusqu'à présent c'est à dire un
gouvernement de la parole où on est
surtout dans la communication plus que
dans l'action et donc je crains qu'il
n'y ait pas de changement de braquet
alors que la situation de notre pays ils
exigent
nous savons qu'à la rentrée on va avoir
un certain nombre de problèmes sociaux
un tsunami social j'allais dire parce
que on voit bien que la crise sanitaire
va entraîner une situation économique
catastrophique avec des plans sociaux
massifs avec un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui vont m
sous la porte et on avait besoin plutôt
d'un gouvernement de combat j'allais
dire pour reconquérir des marchés
remontent et l'économie faire en sorte
que notre pays passe cette situation de
crise le mieux possible et j'ai plutôt
l'impression encore une fois qu'on va se
retrouver comme par le passé comme
jusqu'à présent dans dans la
communication à tout va tout crin plutôt
que dans l'action
alors même si le député a l'air n'est
pas satisfait ce soir que vanille en
benjamins a marre on vous imagine
bouillonnant benjamin marc même si votre
position dans votre chaise et ne peuvent
pas vraiment mais eux j'imagine que vous
n'êtes pas vraiment satisfait de ce
nouveau gouvernement
deux constats le premier constat d'abord
c'est que quand même c'est un
remaniement qui survient après la
pandémie due qu'aux vide alors que quand
on avait écouté les grands discours d'
emmanuel macron pouvait se dire bon on
va avoir effectivement une gouvernement
à la hauteur de cet enjeu historique va
écouter on se retrouve avec une armée
d'épervier qui ressemble étrangement
quand même à celle qu'on connaît
maintenant depuis un certain temps donc
ça veut dire que visiblement emmanuel
macron et sa révolution copernicienne de
la politique est bien échoue
lamentablement avec un déficit en terme
de 2 comment dire d'attractivité tout
simplement ça c'est le premier constat
ensuite on a quand même effectivement
parce qu'on a le sentiment même qu'on a
été racler les fonds de tiroir et on n'a
pas effectivement de prise de guerre
donc ça veut dire clairement qu'il ya un
déficit d'attractivité puis la deuxième
chose quand moi j'ai écouté la liste là
sur les chaînes d'information je me suis
dit mais alors et claude guéant et brice
hortefeux et son ministre de quoi parce
que franchement le maquereau nisme
ressemblait de plus en plus aux sacs aux
archaïsmes
mais là on voit que ça s'accélère où se
retrouvent même avec madame bachelot qui
revient monsieur darmanin monsieur le
maire monsieur castex qui était encore
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours un membre
dlr donc voilà j'ai en moi je fais
partie de ceux qui disent depuis un
certain temps que le et en même temps
n'était qu'une mascarade
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises donc c'est
l'occasion de le redire
emmanuel macron c'est un peu comme le
capitaine crochet il a pas deux jambes
il a une jambe il a une jambe droite
hyper musclé hypertrophié et la jambe
gauche
c'est une jambe de bois et aujourd'hui
cet homme cette mascarade du en même
temps elle apparaît aux yeux de tous
même l'éditorialiste le plus obséquieux
ne peut nier cette réalité
sébastien huyghe vous qu'est ce que vous
auriez souhaité parce que c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron veut tracer les contours
de ce nouveau chemin il l'a dit
reconstruire l'économie le social
l'environnemental le culturel dans notre
pays
qu'est ce qu'il fallait pour cela pour
créer le choc parce qu'on le sait c'est
une question d'équilibré il ya 2022 qui
se profile pour le président de la
république dont le gros problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que le
président de la république a un vrai
problème de ressources humaines et donc
il est obligé de recycler les anciens
ministres du gouvernement sortant pour
les remettre à une autre place alors que
il y avait la nécessité comme j'ai dit à
quelques instants d'un gouvernement de
combat où on met des personnes nouvelles
avec une ligne qui soit très claire pour
l'avenir remettre une grande majorité
des anciens ministres ça veut dire
conserver la ligne précédente qui a le
mandat
lamentablement échoué et donc c'est vrai
que la nomination de monsieur cap tech
castex pardon hein matignon était un
signe qui pouvait apparaître positif en
termes d'idées c'est un grand serviteur
de l'état mais la problématique c'était
qu'on était à nouveau un haut
fonctionnaire à matignon est donc le
sentiment que ça donne c'est on a avant
tout finalement un gouvernement qui vit
qui est fait de hauts fonctionnaires
administratifs techniciens technocrates
qui sont finalement assez éloigné de la
réalité de ce que vivent les français au
quotidien qu'il y ait son âme
eric dupond moretti vous en pensez-quoi
benjamin
marre de cette nomination de cet avocat
qui selon marine le pen est plutôt
classe et militant extrême gauche qui
aimerait bien voir disparaître le rn 1
selon la présidente du rassemblement
national vous êtes plutôt satisfait au
moins par cette nomination alors bon
conte marine le pen dit que monsieur
dupont moretti et d'extrême gauche vous
savez dans la bouche dans la bouche des
crypto fasciste
j'ai envie de dire olivier faur pourrait
passer pour marxiste léniniste donc
c'est assez rigolo au cutter ou moins
monsieur dupont moretti est
incontestablement quelqu'un de brillant
qui connaît son dossier et au sein de la
macro ni déjà c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas évident pour tout le monde a
donc là au moins on attend et on
s'accordera sur le fait que c'est
quelqu'un de brillant ce tome avocat
brillant mais dont je garde un certain
nombre de deux commentaires d'opposition
que je ne partage pas du tout moi je me
souviens de la défense au moment du
procès de georges tron et la manière
dont il s'est est pris aux féministes et
aux plaignantes
je la trouvais j'avais trouvé ça
scandaleux il y a des fois où ses prises
de position et en tant qu avocat me
sembles courageuse et aller contre la
réaction ça n'est pas systématique
j'ai été assez mais choquée de la façon
dont ils avaient dont il avait évoqué le
parquet national financier en évoquant
alors contre lequel il avait porté
plainte et qu'il avait qualifié de tarés
bon voilà donc il ya à boire et à manger
mais je vais vous dire quand on rentre
quand on accepte peut-être par suicide
ego d'être ministre pour emmanuel macron
moi je vous le dis je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose dans la
feuille de route du maquereau nisme j'ai
beaucoup de mal à s'imaginer qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose de correct
savez la justice et le manque de moyen
en france la justice en france
au sein des pays de l' ocde elle souffre
d'un manque de moyens
je dirais une cruelle la question est de
savoir est ce que monsieur dupont
moretti va pouvoir mettre pas pouvoir
mettre sa verve au service justement de
cette grande cause qui consiste à
contenir des moyens budgétaires pour la
justice s'il obtient ça sera déjà pas
mal
les gens doutent j'en doute fortement
autre nomination qui est très commentée
évidemment celle de gérald darmanin
à l'intérieur exit christophe castaner
vous êtes plutôt satisfait sur ce point
là sébastien oui il faudra forcément
mieux selon vous que ce très très proche
des manuels mâcon qui finalement été mis
sous bonne touche sur écoute et je pense
que c'était important que que chris que
christophe castaner sortent du goût du
gouvernement notamment après les
déclarations qu'il avait eue contre les
policiers alors qu'il est censé être le
premier flic de france
clairement il avait vilipendé les
policiers alors qu'il fallait les
soutenir nous avons les les policiers
l'une des meilleures polices au monde
c'est pas parce qu'il ya quelques bruits
brebis galeuses qu'il fallait jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des forces de
sécurité de notre pays et donc il est
normal qu'il soit sorti du gouvernement
après j'allais dire une série de bourdes
très importante après la la nomination
de gérald darmanin posées aux quelques
questions puisque il est sous le coup de
la justice est ce que c'était
véritablement sa place par contre
charles d'arman assez bon il a un beau
parcours en tant qu'élu de la république
et il avait été ministre des comptes
publics maintenant il accède au
ministère de l'intérieur
la question va être là la politique qui
va le mener qui va aller là-bas
la dernière question pour vous benjamin
a marre vous garder en tant que histoire
de profs professeur pardon différentes
géographie vous gardez votre ministre
blanc car vous devez travées a coûté on
est ravi ah c'est la définition même de
la double peine c'est à dire que on a à
la fois tout le mal que l'on pense du
gouvernement mais par contre on concerne
monsieur blanc caire qui a des relations
exécrables avec les syndicats
d'enseignants qui s'est distingué quand
même à rappelons le par son brio ou
maman de la pandémie on se souvient que
le jeudi matin il a annoncé que les
cours se était maintenue dans les
cole et le soir on apprenait que les
écoles étaient fermées ensuite on
connaît tout l'épisode et toute la halle
toute la saga autour de la fermeture de
la réouverture des écoles alors qu'en
italie en espagne des clusters
comparable à la france les écoles
étaient fermés jusqu'en effectivement il
est et les cours ne reprenais qu'en
septembre
donc dans le monde de l'enseignement on
est vraiment ravi de conserver monsieur
blanc caire honnêtement c'est un cadeau
c'est un c'est un magnifique cadeau de
congés scolaires
on est ravis dans les écoles à mon avis
on a dû faire je pense d'un certain
nombre de brasiers de joie merci
benjamin on vous souhaiter de bonnes
vacances on espère que vous avez pas
partir trop énervé merci également à
vous sébastien oui on va avant
d'accueillir nos deux prochains invités
laurent jacobellis et gérard onesta on
va se faire un petit résumé justement de
ces nominations ce soir
[Musique]
oh
e
[Musique]
mais
et on continue avec les réactions à
cette nouvelle équipe castex troisième
gouvernement mais qu'on l'orangé kobe
lee porte parole du rassemblement
national bonsoir vous avez rejoint à vos
côtés gérard onesta conseiller régional
europe ecologie les verts d'occitanie
bonsoir à vous avez également gérard
onesta on commence par vous l'orangé
kobenni que vous inspire dans sa
globalité
ce nouveau gouvernement un nouveau
gouvernement vous êtes optimiste moi je
parlerais de grands recyclage
on a repris les mêmes et on recommence
ce qui veut bien dire que emmanuel
macron à s'entêter dans sa politique
s'entêter dans sa politique de casse
sociale avec la réforme des retraites et
de l'assurance chômage
s'entêter à une politique d'immigration
incontrôlée s'entêter à accepter la
mondialisation qui fait perdre des
emplois en france
non il n'y a rien de neuf sous le soleil
nous avait promis un big bang
on se retrouve avec une tempête dans un
verre d'eau alors bon il ya bien deux
innovations
madame bachelot qui était en manque de
médias on voyait qu'elle courait les
plateaux télé elle aurait sûrement pris
danse avec les stars si on l'avait
proposée elle a pris là le ministère de
la culture on se demande pourquoi
et monsieur dupont moretti alors là
c'est beaucoup plus grave parce que
monsieur dupont moretti
c'est l'homme qui veut lever l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux
dupond moretti c'est l'homme qui veut
interdire le rassemblement national
autant vous dire que l'indépendance de
la justice
et bien c'est pas pour demain et puis
c'est l'homme qui s'est dit honoré et
fier de défendre le frère de mohamed
merah vous voyez on pensait qu'on avait
atteint le pire avec le gouvernement
précédent avec ma prendrai jamais déçu
il ya toujours une étape supplémentaire
vers le shu alors gérard onesta on va
s'arrêter quelques instants évidemment
on vous interrogera forcément sur ce qui
vous intéresse aussi beaucoup le
ministère de l'écologie met sur eric
dupond moretti c'est vrai que ça a créé
la surprise alors une déclaration de
guerre à la magistrature a new deal lui
et c'est bien le principal syndicat de
magistrats a life psa commence un petit
peu mal an
car avec ces magistrats une réaction sur
cette nomination pour la moins
surprenante
et bien déjà il faudrait dire que le
mécanisme même dénomination des
ministres français pourrait être
perfectible - je voudrais souligner
quelque chose qu'il n'ait été relevé par
aucun commentateur et que l'ancien
vice-président du parlement où personne
que je suis ne peut pas laisser sous
silence
en france la nomination de l'exécutif
est le fait du prince
vous voulez du pont mouret qui il a vu
pour moretti au niveau européenne
commissaire européen sont proposés
uniquement proposé au parlement européen
qui les auditionne par écrit par oral
longuement fait de tester la compétence
d'apprécier les projets il arrive que
les impétrants soit retoqué là c'est un
jeu de chaises musicales où il faut
choyer les uns rassurer les autres n'ont
pas de ministère à l'autre sans se
demander si elle a moins de compétences
derrière on essaie de capter quelques
grandes gueules de ce soir en termes de
démocratie avancée parce qu'on peut
quand même imaginer mieux et moi ça me
choque de voir mon pays qui se targuent
d'être des phares de la démocratie dans
le monde fonctionnait encore en comme ça
gérard onesta
ce n'est pas la première fois ce n'est
pas le fait en tout cas d' emmanuel
macron sais c'est toute la vème
république et son fonctionnement qu'il
faudrait changer selon vous bien oui on
se moque souvent de la démocratie
européenne qui a également largement
perfectible mais au moins pour désigner
l'exécutif c'est beaucoup plus
transparent et on regarde qu'investir
des compétences derrière et pas
simplement si on a séduit le prince la
soul est différente république française
c'est toujours le fait du prince ou à
défaut avec de bonnes surprises
moi je suis tout certaine tendresse pour
roselyne bachelot que je connus par
ailleurs et qui a quand même eu le
courage à un moment donné comme sa
famille politique ou au moment du pacs
et du mariage pour tous deux de
s'affirmer là quand même que co
conviction alors je ne sais pas c'est la
culture c'est elle s'épanouira et alep
allegra l'artiste mais pour le coup
c'est peut-être une bonne pioche alors
on y reviendra évidemment gérard laurent
jacot mairie
c'est un gouvernement qui selon vous est
prêt à mettre sur orbite
emmanuel macron pour 2022 mais oui c'est
ça en fait la vraie chose qu'il faut
souligner ce soir c'est que ce
gouvernement
finalement a juste fait pour écarter
doit edouard philippe qu'il faut faire
ou non au président de la république
alors on a mis quelqu'un d'un peu plus
ternes en tout cas on le suppose qui est
monsieur castex mais on regarde derrière
le même gouvernement c'est un lifting a
fait un calcul tout de même des manuels
macron de faire ça parce qu edouard
philippe très bien ressurgir en 2022
face à emmanuel macron c'est un pari
c'est vrai on a bien compris qu'il
fallait qu'il envoie des signaux aux
français qui n'en pouvaient plus de sa
politique qui ne supporte plus son
arrogance écrit plusieurs qu'il prend
donc il a dit on va faire un ravalement
façade la boutique n'attire chalon alors
on va reprendre l'extérieur donc sa peau
de monsieur castex et puis on a dit vous
allez avoir de nouveaux produits
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait c'est
exactement la même chose on reprend les
mêmes et ancien ministre et on les
change de ministère pour certains et
bien derrière la même marchandise
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
mondialisation à outrance la casse
sociale l'immigration bref rien n'a
changé emmanuel macron s'est juste fait
ce soir alif king à moindre prix mais
que les français soient dupes
alors avant de l'interroger à nouveau
gérard nsa écouter ces quelques
réactions recueillies sur les réseaux
sociaux
un gouvernement libéral banal
castanet rb loubet honte de l'intérieur
et de la justice
enfin démissionner darmanin et dupond
moretti doivent rétablir la dignité et
l'honneur à la justice est nommé en
militant d'extrême gauche qui souhaite
l'interdiction du rassemblement national
premier parti d'opposition
ça promet si bête et castaner dehors
petit bonheur du soir
pour le reste on reprend largement les
mêmes et on recommence et je m'attends à
une belle pagaille à la justice avec
dupond moretti
de toute façon tous européiste donc zéro
changement possible les français
voulaient changer de politique et garder
le même premier ministre
emmanuel macron a fait exactement
l'inversé il change le premier ministre
mais avec ce nouveau gouvernement
on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement politique alors pas de
changements politiques selon dupont
aignan est-ce qu'il y en aura une selon
vous gérard onesta dans ce qui vous
intéresse le domaine de l'écologie avec
la nomination de barbares accompli leur
barbara c'est une femme de conviction au
pluriel
elle a souvent changé les nommés à la
transition écologique ça lui va bien
elle est toujours en transit et c'est
par les écologistes
elle était ensuite dans un gouvernement
socialiste
maintenant chez makro je pense que son
parcours n'est pas terminée vous savez
en politique il faut choisir soit on
veut faire son voeu durée elle a décidé
elle de durée nicolas hulot et
l'inénarrable monsieur d'origine et au
premier rang protocolaire est aberrant
ministre d'état ont déjà été rétrogradé
ça c'est pour la place de l'écologie
et surtout nicolas hulot disait que si
bercy ministère des finances n'était pas
en phase avec l'écologie on ne pouvait
rien faire et qui est ce soir le grand
et unique attend désormais des merci
bruno le maire grand adorateur de la
bagnole et plus grands défenseurs du
nucléaire
autant dire que le match est plié
l'écologie restera décoratifs voilà sens
de la formule de gérard onesta l'orangé
comédie vous partager cette analyse
parce que c'est vrai on l'attendait ce
poste là après l'éclatante voilà
l'éclatant succès des verts aux
municipales et aux européennes un petit
peu avant mais ce gouvernement ne peut
pas être écologiste pour une bonne
raison c'est qu'il croit trouant la
mondialisation y croient trop au libre
échange sans règles et sans contrôle
pour se soucier d'écologie l'écologie
c'est quoi c'est pas mais qu'il monde en
protéines est électrique et empêcher les
automobilistes d'aller au travail pour
suivre les agriculteurs ou les chasseurs
ça cette icône une écologie le
castratrice est souvent représentée par
les verts
personne n'en veut elle ne serait pas
utile dans la vrai que le gie c'est
produire près de chez soi
consommer ce qui est produit près de
chez soi d'abord parce que c'est une
meilleure qualité de vie ça crée des
emplois et puis surtout ça diminue
l'empreinte carbone parce que les
produits ne viennent pas du canada des
états unis de chine
ça ce serait
mesure écologique intelligente et
relance rennes en cours en ce qui serait
pour voyants d'un vrai patriotisme
économique dont on a tant besoin
mais évidemment c'est faire à la nature
même de l'idéologie mondialiste libéral
gérard onesta le mot de la fin parce que
c'est vrai qu emmanuel macron nous avait
annoncé un grand changement avec tombeau
tambours et trompettes 1 1 lors de ce
discours post co vide qu'est ce qui va
se passer est ce qu'on peut imaginer en
énorme changement n'a entendu déjà jean
castex nous prévenir que la réforme des
retraites est bien ça serait lancé dès
l'été le ségur de la santé a priori on
n'a pas changé de ministre donc ça
devrait suivre son cours qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de vraiment
révolutionnaire pour cette troisième
partie de mandat bien on se rend compte
que ce soir que le vivier de la macro me
est à sec
ici nous trouver personne pour essayer
de changer les têtes d'affiché de ce
gouvernement en terme de personnel c'est
à sec mais en termes d'idées ça reste à
sec également
on ne change pas un gars de des
ministres même de droite du rhin parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que monsieur
gérald darmanin viennent de la droite
c'est assez extrêmes au départ un dôme
m6 s'est recentrée dans ses propos on
connaît on connaît le parcours sur sur
l'économie c'est le libéralisme à tout
crin qui triomphe ce soit quant à
l'écologie paradoxalement nos milieux
girouette n'a pas forcément fait avancer
des hauts lieux
merci laurent jats comédiens on
terminera sur cette jolie formule merci
gérard onesta également d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et on
disait dont christophe castaner place
beauvau pour lui c'est terminé le
désormais ex ministre de l'intérieur et
remplacé par gérald darmanin dont on
parlait à l'instant longtemps annoncé
partant
ancien socialiste quitte finalement son
poste à la suite du remaniement voulu
par emmanuel macron un bilan mitigé pour
celui qui a dû affronter la plus grave
crise sociale depuis 1968 et aux combes
avec karzaï selon la formule consacrée
christophe castaner n'aura jamais fait
autant honneur à l'expression
arrivée à beauvau pour remplacer gérard
collomb ce partisan de la première heure
des manuels macron successivement porte
parole du gouvernement puis secrétaire
d'état en charge des relations avec le
parlement se retrouvent d'abord sous le
feu des projecteurs
nous avons travaillé ensemble depuis la
nomination du premier gouvernement dans
une relation politique et de confiance
avec christophe castaner et je suis
certain que vous êtes parfaitement armé
est totalement déterminée pour faire
face à cette mission un éphémère moment
de grâce un mois après sa nomination
christophe castaner doit faire face à un
mouvement de contestation inédit celui
des gilet jaune à partir de novembre
2018 samedi après samedi
la situation se tend entre
protestataires et forces de l'ordre
les débordements se multiplient jusqu'au
1er décembre date à laquelle les champs
elysées ressemble à un véritable champ
de bataille
sous pression après ses débordements
christophe castaner tente de calmer le
jeu nous avons souhaité faire un geste
de dialogue pour les gilet jaune qui
voulaient sept axes stratégiques que
sont les champs elysées alors que tous
les ministres de l'intérieur savent que
c'est très difficile de tenir ce lieu
est longue toujours interdite mais le
courant ne passe déjà plus avec les
manifestants le maintien de l'ordre se
fait plus stricte les tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes et de l bd se généralise
des armes dont il ne cessera de défendre
l' usage une stratégie de l'affrontement
qui porte sa marque et qui laisse des
cicatrices
plusieurs centaines des borniers des
mains arrachées et un discours qui ne
laisse plus aucune place au dialogue
nos forces de sécurité seront mobilisés
totalement mobilisée et je suis serein
parce que je sais qu'elles savent
toujours faire face
ça n'empêche pas la violence mais elles
savent répondre de façon proportionnelle
à maîtriser les situations et au fil dès
samedi
évidemment nous avons la maîtrise du
terrain honni des gilet jaune
il représente un tournant sécuritaire du
quinquennat multipliant les saillies
verbales à leur encontre des propos qui
extrapolez
parfois la réalité notamment lorsqu'il
dénonce la prétendue attaque de
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière par
les protestataires
de fausses informations sur lesquels il
revient quelques jours plus tard on
retient aussi son silence suite à la
mort de steve mailhac à nice au ce jeune
homme tombé dans la loire à nantes en
jouant 2019 à la suite d'une opération
de police controversé
fervent défenseur de l'institution
policière sa relation avec cette
dernière s'effrite
semaine après semaine pensé pour sa
gestion de l'attaqué terroriste de la
préfecture de police de paris en octobre
le lien se coupe définitivement après
les manifestations contre le racisme du
début du mois de juin dernier sa volonté
de supprimer la technique dite de
l'étranglement crée alors une fronde
chez les policiers et gendarmes
soyez les bienvenus quasiment 21h30 en
direct sur rt france après un business
man et si le prochain locataire de la
maison blanche et est un rappeur
l'artiste américain kanye west a annoncé
hier vouloir briguer la présidence des
états unis en novembre prochain
malgré ses faibles chances d'y arriver
cette candidature peut-elle changer la
donne
éléments de réponse avec estelle farges
un duel donald trump versus joe biden
jusqu'à présent la course à la maison
blanche se limitait à une confrontation
entre ces deux hommes mais le 4 juillet
dernier en tweets a quelque peu perturbé
le cours de la campagne présidentielle
américaine un tweet signé kanye west
nous devons maintenant accomplir la
promesse de l'amérique en ayant
confiance en dieu en unifiant nos
visions et en construisant notre avenir
je suis candidat à la présidence des
états unis pour le moment le rappeur
hommes d'affaires et milliardaire de 43
ans n'a pas fourni davantage de détails
sur ses intentions
impossible donc de savoir s'il s'agit
d'une plaisanterie ou d'une réelle
ambition toujours est il que kanye west
a déjà reçu quelques soutiens et
notamment celui d'ellen masquer le
patron de tesla aux 36 millions
d'abonnés sur twitter
mais dans les rues de new york les
réactions sont beaucoup plus mitigées
c'est de la folie c'est une idée folle
je veux dire ce pays est déjà foutu pour
commencer a ajouté cela cette idée et
nous serons complètement perdu je pense
que c'est une super idée parce que je
pense qu'il est temps pour les états
unis de se débarrasser de trump nous
sommes fatigués de lui nous ne voulons
pas de trump pour président vous ne
pouvez pas donner un président en
seulement quatre ans pour diriger un
pays il a besoin de plus et tout ça pour
vous dire que je donne un peu ma faveur
à trump en le traitant correctement il a
besoin de quatre ans supplémentaires
pour voir ce qu'il pourrait faire c'est
un bon type et ce n'est pas la première
fois que l'artiste évoque cette ambition
présidentielle en 2015 à la cérémonie
des mtv video awards kanye west avait
déjà deux nuls 20 en tête et puis plus
récemment en 2010 neuf lors d'une
interview dans beats one show une
émission d'appels musique l'homme avait
affirmé qu'il serait un jour à la tête
du pays
il viendra un temps où je serai le
président des états unis et je me
souviendrai de tout fondateur qui n'aura
pas été capables de comprendre
culturellement ce que nous faisons il
s'agit d'idées et mon frère de nouvelles
idées des gens avec des idées des gens
qui croient à la vérité et oui comme
vous l'avez probablement deviné à ce
moment là j'ai décidé en 2020 de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
on peut aussi citer l'une des paroles de
son titre fact en 2020 je gagnerai
l'élection une candidature qui selon
certains analystes n'apportera rien
d'autre qu'une division
et votre côté démocrate qu'est-ce qu'a
kanye west à nous offrir rien il ne
proposera rien de plus
tout ce qu'il fera c'est diviser les
votes des démocrates les gens côté
conservateurs républicains eux ne
voteront pas pour kanye west il pourrait
peut-être attirer les voix des jeunes
mais ce vote jeunes n'a jamais à mon
avis et n'aura jamais sans doute une
grande influence sur les élections que
dans mon groupe d'âge les 40 ans et plus
n'iront pas voter pour kanye west
lc 10 sans animosité envers lui c'est
juste leur regard sur ce qu'il pourra
réellement accomplir mais kanye west
peut-il réellement devenir le 46e
président des états unis peu probable
premièrement parce qu'ils ne possèdent
l'investiture d'aucun parti il faudrait
donc qu'il se présente en candidat
indépendant
l'histoire des états unis nous a montré
qu'un candidat ni républicain ni
démocrate n'avait aucune chance
d'accéder à la victoire
et puis deuxièmement le temps presse
l'élection et dans quatre mois ce qui
laisse peu de marge aux rappeurs pour
remplir toutes les formalités
administratives afin d'entrer dans la
course si 2020 semble quasiment joué
pour kanye west l'artiste pourrait
reporter son ambition à 2024
l'homme a toujours affiché son soutien à
donald trump et il n'est pas impossible
qu'ils entendent briguer l'investiture
républicaine dans quatre ans autre
interrogation et si cette candidature
cash est plutôt un bon coup de com
l'artiste a en effet sorti le 30 juin
dernier soit quatre jours avant son
tweet un single qui annonce l'arrivée de
son nouvel album god scontri la question
mérite d'être posée
et pour en parler nous retrouvons en
direct d'atlanta aux états unis ben swan
journaliste d'investigation c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir ban souad merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors cette
candidature de ce rappeur kanye west
comment at elle été prise aux etats-unis
est-ce qu'elle a été prise au sérieux
s'il attire et c'est assez intéressant
lorsque donald trump a annoncé sa
candidature en 2016
beaucoup de personnes ont dit c'est
d'absurde
comment un homme d'affaires milliardaire
et un présentateur de télé réalité
pourrait-il devenir président et non
seulement il a reçu l'investiture mais
également il a remporté la maison
blanche
et cela introduit une nouvelle idée
selon laquelle on n'a pas forcément
besoin de choisir se présentant dans les
cercles condom et de femmes politiques
de washington des gouverneurs ou des
sénateurs
mais ce qui est très intéressant avec
l'annnonce de kanye west c'est qu'il
faut regarder
l'électorat qu'il vise en 2016 lorsque
donald trump été contre hillary clinton
y avait beaucoup de place pour un
candidat indépendant parce que certaines
personnes apprécié d'un troll mais
beaucoup de personnes le détester et
beaucoup de personne n'aimait pas non
plus hillary clinton
et pourtant il n'y avait que deux
options pour eux annonce sa candidature
mais beaucoup de personnes considèrent
effectivement que c'est une alternative
et pour beaucoup d'autres personnes il
pourrait s'agir d'une opération
publicitaire et beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui disent oui ils ont sérieux
et il a peut-être même lâche de la
chance de gagner
alors vous vous faites vous même la
comparaison avec donald trump quand il
s'est présenté à la candidature
kanye west lui jusqu'à quel point
justement selon vous petit lob
bouleverser cette présidentielle
ne sera sans doute pas un candidat très
fort parce que c'est politique propre ne
lui permettent pas forcément d'être un
bon candidat et nous savons pas
exactement ce que l'électorat pourrait
voter pour lui il a l'argent nécessaire
il a la position et il peut répandre son
message mais nous ne connaissons pas
exactement ce message ne savons pas son
programme ne savons pas ce qui fait de
lui un meilleur candidat
kanye west s'est positionné comme un
rappeur protruck aux états unis ce qui
est vraiment une couche très étroite de
la société il porte la casquette rouge
emblématique de donald trump sa femme
kim kardashian l'ouest et lui-même se
soit rendu plusieurs fois à la maison
blanche
kim kardashian a travaillé avec donald
trump sur des réformes judiciaires
donc il a vraiment une position très
spécifiques et cela fait déjà plusieurs
années quatre cinq voire six ans qu'il
dit vouloir concourir en 2020 donc c'est
intéressant qu'il ait choisi cette année
et certaines personnes considéraient
qu'il attendrait 2024 lorsque donald
trump ne serait plus en lice
il y aura des gens qui n'aiment pas de m
il y aura des gens qui n'ont pas non
plus le candidat démocrate joe dalton
est-ce que kanye west représentera une
alternative viable pour ces personnes ou
un autre candidat sans doute plus
légitime
apparaîtra-t-il alors il ya quand même
la question vous dites voilà c'est
quelque chose qui était pensé depuis
longtemps mais il ya quand même la
question du timing il sut prend plutôt
tard gagné ouest pour annoncer cette
candidature déjà il est hors délai
peut-être dans certains états et puis on
ne sait pas s'il va faire cavalier seul
ou s'il va essayer de se greffer un
petit parti ça ne s'improvise pas tout
ça tout à fait il serait forcé de
concourir en tant que candidat
indépendant
mais cela ne serait pas un problème
parce qu'il suffirait d'être inscrit sur
le scrutin dans les états les plus
importants
il va y avoir une rhétorique autour de
camille ouest disant qu'il pourrait
égaler la situation si ils votent pour
kanye west plutôt que tu chopes hayden
alors pour les démocrates c'est un vote
pour d'autres et si on vote pour kanye
west hall et de donald trump pour les
républicains c'est un vote pour joe
biden donc on dira que voter pour kanye
west c'est voter pour l'autre candidat
celui qu'on n'aime pas donc la
rhétorique va être très très controversé
mais c'est une bonne chose en quelque
sorte parce que cela permet d'éviter des
critiques du fait du manque de temps
mais je pense que kanye west se lance
dans une tempête pour laquelle il n'est
pas prêt car il ya vraiment beaucoup de
critiques beaucoup de polémiques autour
des candidats et je pense que kanye west
va toutefois pas souffrir de cela alors
c'est vrai aussi qu'une sort un album
kanye west du coup toutes les chaînes on
parle il n'y a pas vraiment de programme
en tout cas vous aviez l'air de dire
qu'on ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'ils
proposent ce que voilà on peut vraiment
prendre clairement cette candidature au
sérieux c'est pas tout simplement un
coup de pub de la part du rappeur qui
connaît très bien les réseaux de
communication en attestent évidemment sa
femme la reine des réseaux sociaux n'est
ce pas chez est absolument l'arrêt des
réseaux sociaux
est-ce que kanye west et sérieux je le
pense il en parle depuis longtemps mais
la question est la suivante est ce que
kanye west qui est une personne très
intéressante
quel que soit votre opinion sur sa
politique ou sa musique at il planifié
la situation at il déjà construit un
programme une chose certaine il réussira
très bien apporter le message
effectivement lui
femmes sont très doués pour cela met la
question et peuvent-ils développer une
stratégie cohérente pour le
développement et le gouvernement
au cours de leur mandat à si c'est le
cas alors effectivement il pourrait
acquérir un certain élan parce que des
gens vont se tourner vers lui en se
disant c'est un candidat sérieux
mais s'il se contente de dire je veux
être candidat à voter pour moi parce que
je ne suis je ne suis ni de n'être ni
tube hayden alors il n'a aucune chance
merci beaucoup benson d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
la france accueille tel sur son sol des
militaires saoudiens enfin qu'il se
forme c'est ce qu'affirme en tout cas
nestier international dans une enquête
publiée ces derniers jours un ancien
site militaire de la meuse servirait de
base d'entraînement pour des soldats du
royaume wahhabite
une situation qui interroge alors que la
guerre au yémen se poursuit thomas
bonnin l'implication présumée de la
france dans la guerre au yémen est
souvent pointée du doigt par des ong
voire même par l'onu qui a épinglé en
septembre dernier le soutien logistique
de certains pays dont la france à la
coalition qui mène la guerre contre les
outils au yémen ces nouvelles
révélations d'amnesty international
risquent de renforcer ces accusations
après plusieurs mois d'enquêté les ong
publie des informations sur la création
d'un centre d'entraînement dans la
commune de commercy dans la meuse un
campus
implanté sur une ancienne base militaire
et qui appartient au groupe belge s'est
mis l'objectif recevoir et former les
clients de l'entreprise en l'occurrence
des militaires saoudiens pour apprendre
la manipulation de tourelles canon
cockerill au programme instructions des
tireurs des pilotes et des mécaniciens
au maniement de sa tourelle et de son
système d'armes d'une capacité de 120
stagiaires le campus cockerill doit
accueillir ses soldats à partir de 2017
et pour sept ans - une formation censée
s'étaler chaque année sur six à neuf
mois dans la paisible campagne française
hôtel
restaurant sauna et mosquées pour créer
une sorte de bulle tout a été pensé pour
placer les militaires saoudiens dans les
meilleures conditions il est très
difficile de savoir si le campus on a
déjà accueilli
écoutez ce qu'en dit audrey lebel
l'auteur de l'article
en off on me dit qu'il y en a qu il y en
a même qui aurait été coincés là bas
pendant toute la crise du coc vide mais
officiellement même les élus locaux
disent ne pas savoir si les formations
véritablement commencé à commerciaux
si la présence des soldats saoudiens
mais pas confirmé l'existence même de ce
campus et de ce programme d'entraînement
font débat car au delà de la situation
géopolitique
ce projet a bénéficié d'argent public
notamment par le biais des aides
accordées par le conseil régional de
lorraine
six cent mille euros avait ainsi été
débloqués en 2015 provoquant de vives
réactions notamment de jacqueline
fontaine qui était à l'époque
conseillère régionale e élevé il y a un
grand décalage entre la présentation
bien pudique du dossier et la réalité du
projet on apprend à faire la guerre à
des saoudiens
on n'est pas sûr qu'on ne les retrouvera
pas un jour face à nous sur un terrain
quelconque
surtout que pour justifier un tel
investissement les retombées économiques
étaient mises en avant retombées dont
les habitants peinent à voir les fruits
encore aujourd'hui plus globalement
cette base d'entraînement pose la
question du soutien de la france à la
coalition saoudienne et émirati au yémen
la secrétaire d'état aux armes et
geneviève darrieussecq s'est d'ailleurs
rendu sur le campus de commercy et en
avril 2019
bien que sous pavillon privé ce centre
semble finalement s'inscrire dans une
volonté exprimée en 2015 par le quai
d'orsay de vouloir encourager je cite
l'augmentation de la coopération sur le
terrain des exercices militaires et de
l'entraînement en arabie saoudite et en
france depuis le monde a pu constater
l'horreur humanitaire créée par cette
guerre au yémen et l'indignation de
l'opinion publique suscite un certain
embarras parmi les lébous
dans des pays exportateurs d'armes en
arabie saoudite
cette base d'entraînement sur le sol
français pourrait là encore être une
épine dans le pied du ministère des
armées et a fortiori pour le président
de la république après la mise en place
le 30 juin dernier de la loi chinoise
sur la sécurité nationale le
gouvernement de hong kong suit le pas le
territoire autonome en effet ordonné
hier de nouvelles mesures répressives et
précision à dylan a fait radio une
feuille blanche
en guise de protestation contre le
retrait de livres scolaires ce lundi
hong kong a en effet ordonné aux écoles
de retirer les livres susceptibles de
violer la nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
nationale un texte qui interdit
désormais toute contestation du pouvoir
chinois he notamment la mise en cause de
l'unité du pays
selon pékin il s'agit de réprimer la
subversion la sécession le terrorisme et
la collusion avec les forces étrangères
et donc d'assurer la stabilité après les
manifestations qui agitent l'ancienne
colonie britannique
depuis 2019 les crimes contre la
sécurité nationale seront ainsi passible
de la prison à vie
de plus les policiers de chine
continentale pourront également et pour
la première fois opéré sur le sol hong
kong et un point d'inflexion entre le
chaos et la bonne gouvernance selon les
mots de la chef de l'exécutif de la
région spéciale autonome je préférerais
ne pas arrêter et ne pas poursuivre
personne si tout le monde respecte la
loi
l'objectif de cette législation n'est
pas seulement de punir mais aussi de
dissuader les gens de commettre des
infractions aussi grave que la sécession
la subversion du pouvoir de l'état où
les activités terroristes
mais cette nouvelle législation ne fait
pas l'unanimité à l'étranger au total 27
pays dont la france le royaume uni et le
japon accuse la chine de vouloir museler
l'opposition à hong kong
ce que dénonce aussi certains activistes
tels que joshua wang
avec le danger pour notre sécurité
personnelle avec la menace d'une peine à
perpétuité
nous pourrions être inquiet aussi être
visés par pékin mais nous encourageons
aussi la communauté internationale à
faire entendre notre voix dans le monde
tant que nous avons encore une chance
nous devons encore faire savoir au monde
que le moment est venu de soutenir on
convient que le moment est venu paul et
hong kong et de poursuivre notre
dynamique
une loi qui pourrait jeter de l'huile
sur le feu de la contestation qui
commençait pourtant à refluer après des
mois d'instabilité mais un climat
d'inquiétude c'est cependant abattus sur
l'archipel aujourd'hui la page blanche
signifie deux choses d'abord ça signifie
que la terreur blanche est ici à hong
kong
la terreur blanche est la conséquence de
la loi de hong kong sur la sécurité
nationale
ensuite nous pensons que la loi de hong
kong sur la sécurité nationale est
littéralement une page blanche
bien que des mots ils soient écrits
l'interprétation de la loi est
littéralement décidée par le parti
communiste chinois
nous sommes inquiets de pouvoir être
condamné pour avoir exprimé nos opinions
car il a nous a dit un jour que le
slogan libérez hong kong la révolution
de notre temps évoquée la sécession
c'est pourquoi nous utilisons plutôt une
page blanche
ce nouveau cadre légal fait ainsi
craindre à l'opposition un recul inédit
des libertés dans le territoire hong
kong et depuis sa rétrocession par les
britanniques en 1997
pékin appelle paris à garantir un
environnement équitable pour les
entreprises chinoises
la france souhaite en effet est
restreinte fortement l'accès de hoyaux
marché français de la singer est des
annonces sur fond de tensions
diplomatiques entre washington et pékin
et précision de clémence pital l'avenir
du géant chinois huawei sur le marché de
la 5g en france s'annonce très incertain
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information l'ansi
annoncé qu'elle limiterait ses licences
d'exploitation à une durée allant de
trois à huit ans ces restrictions
concernerait les opérateurs français
comme sfr ou bouygues telecom qui
utiliserait les équipements de huawei
pour déployer l'internet mobile de
cinquième génération
il n'y aura pas un bannissement total
les opérateurs qui n'utilisent pas
ouailles nous les incitons à ne pas y
aller car c'est un peu le sens naturel
des choses
nous ne sommes pas dans du why bashing
ni dans du racisme anti chinois ou
disons juste que le risque n'est pas le
même avec des équipementiers européens
qu'avec des non européens
il ne faut pas se mentir après cette
décision défavorable au géant chinois
des télécommunications la diplomatie
chinoise et mais l'espoir de voir la
france
garantir un environnement équitable à
ces entreprises
la chine espère que la partie française
pour observer une attitude objective et
juste respecter les lois du marché et la
volonté des entreprises en les laissant
faire leur choix de façon indépendante
et dans leur propre intérêt et adopter
des mesures concrètes pour mettre en
place un environnement ouvert équitable
et non discriminatoire pour les
entreprises de tous les pays y compris
les entreprises chinoises une chambre a
nié huawei numéro deux mondial de la
téléphonie et surtout leader des
équipements 5 g le groupe est depuis
plusieurs années scrutées par les états
unis qui affirme le soupçonné
d'espionnage au profit de pékin
washington fait donc pression sur ses
alliés pour qu'ils bannissent huawei
pour raisons de sécurité
mais certains observateurs estiment
qu'il s'agit surtout pour washington de
protéger les champions américains du
secteur fragilisé par leur retard
technologique sur la 5g en europe le
royaume uni devrait annoncer ce mois-ci
des dispositions imposant le retrait
progressif des équipements huawei du
réseau 5g du pays
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve à 22 heures
pile pour un point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
il
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck salle que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent nos
résidents de six personnes non non c'est
pas vrai il ya des climats tous et non
ce n'est pas rien à part il ya des gens
qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat le gars plus de
débats aujourd'hui ya plus aucun débat
ce changement climatique qui on va faire
un vrai par une catastrophe ou 20 vers
une vraie catastrophe et on est
incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi vient
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pour moi
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates les activistes et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste fonds
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine des bâches me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup disent que la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver pensé que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérante
alors parfois elle s'était imposée
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde à man
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
et
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
la preuve nous avions déjà commencé à
utiliser le protocole avec les gothiques
préoccupe bien avant que le match ne
commence en effet par sénégal la
chloroquine domaniale est utilisé
pendant des décennies et des décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les sénégalais
quand j'entends de dinan il n'y a pas de
signes qui mettent en doute ces
protocoles
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
oh
bref france pour renault ce sont des
entreprises qui seront je dirais en fait
permanente
on va obliger les entreprises un
contexte actuel à garder leurs salariés
ça n'a pas de sens
ça fait longtemps que je soutiens une
des emplois garantis
c'est dire on propose un emploi toutes
ces personnes ont maintenant qu'elle
retrouve un autre jeune dont on n'a
aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de non activité où les billetteries sont
à l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un rare démarche sous conditions
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
de ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché cela
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
in trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il y à une impunité assumer il y a
une culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
le gouvernement quel sexe a désormais un
visage une équipe de seize ministres et
de 14 ministres délégués quelques
surprises également huit nouveaux
ministres font leur entrée au
gouvernement mme gauron barbara profili
à la transition écologique est réglé
pour moretti et la justice dans une
vache l'eau et la culture l'ancien
ministre du budget le sarkozyste gérald
darmanin succès avec christophe castaner
place beauvau le royaume uni
l'union européenne ont repoussé à demain
la reprise de leurs négociations en
visant à surmonter
verge en importance qui persiste sur
leur relation aux briques site le
calendrier devient de plus en plus
serrée pour éviter un mobile risque et
économiquement situation préoccupante en
iran sur le plan des crises du coc vide
le bilan quotidien des décès n'a jamais
été aussi élevé 160 nouveaux décès en 24
heures portant à plus de 2700 m
l'épidémie les autorités iraniennes sont
critiqués pour leur question de la crise
gestion des crises le port du masque
devient obligatoire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez le suspense a
pris fin peu après 19 heures ce soir le
secrétaire général de l'elysée lexsi
colère a dévoilé à la composition du
gouvernement castex ont fait le point
avec notre reporter katia technique à
l'elysée ce nouveau gouvernement ne
s'illustre pas par son effet de surprise
mais plutôt par une parité homme-femme
et l'accession à des postes clés
d'anciennes figures de la droite alors
concernant les ministres qui ont gardé
leur poste bruno le maire reste à bercy
florence parly reste ministre des armées
jean michel blanquer
reste à l'éducation libérant à la santé
en revanche au niveau des chaises
musicales et elisabeth borne pas du
transport au travail et du lin de
normandie par exemple du logement à
l'agriculture la première semi surprise
c'est l'accession de barbara pompili au
poste de ministre de la transition
écologique
c'est une ancienne transfuge d'europe
écologie les verts passés chez rml suis
vraiment la ligne du parti donc il n'y
aura pas de choc de cultures comme avec
nicolas hulot est d'ores et déjà les
voix écologistes s'élèvent contre ce
choix
les surprises maintenant il s'agit de
l'arrivée de gérald darmanin la place
beauvau ce jeune homme de 37 ans a été
préférée et donc à jean michel blanquer
qui devait être pressenti il aura la
lourde tâche de regagner la confiance de
la police c'était un ministère qui était
sous le feu des critiques à cause de la
gestion de christophe castaner alors une
petite précision au titre des polémiques
il faut quand même dire que gérald
darmanin est actuellement sous le coup
d'une enquête judiciaire
une autre surprise la nomination de
roselyne bachelot
cet ancien ministre de la santé avait
quitté la politique pour devenir
chroniqueuse télé
eh bien elle devient
ministre de la culture la plus grande
surprise ce nouveau gouvernement c'est
eric dupond moretti
nommé en tant que garde des sceaux ce
célèbre avocat pénaliste surnommé
aquitator à sobriquet qu'il n'aime pas
mais qui rappelle sa compétence pour
faire acquitter ses clients c'était le
défenseur notamment de patrick balkany
bernard tapie encore abdelkader meira il
faut noter dans son actualité est très
en colère contre le parquet financier
en effet celui-ci l'a fait mettre sur
écoute dans une affaire de corruption
impliquant nicolas sarkozy sinon une
pléthore de poste de ministre délégué a
été créée donc on y retrouve franck
riester recaser de la culture au
commerce extérieur et marlène schiappa
qui devient délégué à la citoyenneté
dans le cadre de ministère de
l'intérieur il faut aussi ajouter que
gabriella talent a été nommé en tant que
porte parole du gouvernement et remplace
ainsi si bête engine et pour didier
maïsto président au nom de sud radio et
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique le nouveau gouvernement
est axé sur la préparation de la
campagne des manuels l'écran pour 2011
sur le fond c'est un gouvernement de
continuité où on a un président de la
république qui finalement poursuit la
ligne qui est la sienne qui évacuent un
certain nombre de ministres qui étaient
les ministres en difficulté je pense aux
mini jeux à l'intérieur je pense à la
porte parole du gouvernement je pense à
la garde des sceaux et qui disons sur le
plan de la symbolique va chercher
quelques personnalités médiatiques qui
permettent finalement de faire oublier
la continuité de ce gouvernement une
saleen politique vraisemblablement est
attiré l'oeil des commentateurs ces
récents - la plus grande surprise c'est
la nomination au poste de garde des
sceaux de monsieur dupont moretti
éventuellement un moindre degré
le de madame bachelot à la culture
quoique je pense que très franchement
c'est un c'est un gouvernement qui
encore une fois ne traduit pas une
rupture fondamentale c'est un
gouvernement très politicien cette
politique tournée vers l'ambition
quasiment ciel de d'emmanuel macron ça
n'aura échappé et pas du tout tourné
vers les français
quand vous voyez c'est des prises a pas
médiatique bachelot qui fait des
émissions de télé sur une chaîne humaine
stream
eric duffaut maire de meaux et ils ont
tout le monde s'accorde à dire
talentueux mais enfin c'est surtout
depuis longtemps un homme médiatique
monsieur nana qui a fait le caprice qui
a menacé de quitter le gouvernement
s'ils n'étaient pas connues il a été
entendu et pourquoi le proche de xavier
bertrand
il permet de neutraliser cette droite
puisque on voit bien aujourd'hui que le
le barycentre les qui vibre de monsieur
m'a continue du tout avec la golf
complètement dans cette droite 103
bourgeois comme ça a été dit est un peu
moins c'est un peu le ventre mou la
démocratie et suite à ces nominations de
nombreuses réactions politiques sur
twitter regarder un gouvernement libéral
banal castanet rb loubet honte de
l'intérieur et de la justice enfants
démissionner darmanin et dupond moretti
doivent rétablir la dignité et l'honneur
à la justice est nommé en militant
d'extrême gauche qui souhaite
l'interdiction du rassemblement national
premier parti d'opposition
ça promet si bête et castaner dehors
petit bonheur du soir
pour le reste on reprend largement les
mêmes et on recommence et je m'attends à
une belle pagaille à la justice avec
dupond moretti
de toute façon tous européiste donc zéro
changement possible les français
voulaient changer de politique et garder
le même premier ministre emmanuel macron
a fait exactement l'inversé
il change le premier ministre mais avec
ce nouveau gouvernement
on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement politique la crise appelait
un changement profond au final c'est un
gouvernement plus à droite que jamais
macron promettait de se réinventer mais
il continue de concentrer tous les
pouvoirs ce n'est pas un gouvernement
c'est un caprice
notre pays a besoin d'un ministre de
l'intérieur efficace gérald darmanin a
les qualités pour assumer cette mission
je sais quel honneur cela représente
pour ce serviteur de l'état
courage et réussite pour le nouveau
gouvernement de jean castex l'engagement
de tous les ministres sera essentiel
pour relever les défis des prochains
mois servir la france et les français et
la plus belle mission qui soit c'est
donc le deuxième remaniement sous la
présidence d manueel macron l'exécutif
qui a déjà connu des démissions et des
départs depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir du
chef de l'état le point en images
[Musique]
on est en reprise des négociations sur
le break sites ont été repoussée à
demain à londres le royaume uni et
l'union européenne peine encore à
définir leurs futures relations
économiques et commerciales
les discussions étaient compliquées à
bruxelles toute la semaine négociateur
européen michel barnier a évoqué de
sérieuses divergences son homologue
britannique david frost a quant à lui
souligné des différences significatives
et date butoir pour ces négociations
prendra fin le 31 décembre mais les
européens souhaitent un accord pour
octobre elle risque d'un odile pourrait
bien être dévastateur pour d économie
déjà fragilisée par la pandémie
coronavirus et pour claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales les
conséquences du break sites seront
douloureuses pour l'économie britannique
je pense que les conséquences
économiques seront assez sérieuse
bien sûr personne ne le souhaite et du
côté européen ni du côté des acteurs
économiques britanniques un odile mais
boris johnson prend elle a adopté une
tactique qui risque fort d'y aboutir
donc en effet il y aura des conséquences
sans doute pour un certain nombre de
secteurs britannique qui suivirent ont
eu des conséquences puisque les
britanniques bien sûr on la majorité de
leurs échanges économiques avec le
continent européen et pas avec d'autres
partenaires plus ou moins chimérique
alors est-ce aussi la question majeure
qui est quid de la city c'est à dire de
la place financière de londres
et là dans le fond c'est les banques qui
vont décider ce sont les institutions
financières qui vont décider est-ce
qu'elles auront plus de liberté en
restantes à londres est ce qu elles
s'installeront sur le continent je pense
qu'elles feront les deux en réalité et
qu'elles joueront en effet sur la paie
leurs possibilités d'arbitrage entre la
législation britannique et la
législation européenne
la situation préoccupe car préoccupante
pardon en iran sur le plan de la crise
du kobe de 19 le bilan quotidien des
décès n'a jamais été aussi élevé 163 en
24 heures le port du masque est donc
désormais obligatoire dans certains
lieux publics couverts notamment dans
les transports en commun réécouter ce
qu'en pense la population et si les
citoyens n'utilise pas de masque nous ne
les laisserons pas entrer dans le métro
de plus la police du métro et y est
également stationnée dans nos terminaux
nous avons déployé nos force exécutive
naturellement nous ne permettrons pas à
ceux qui n'ont pas de masque de monter
dans le bus comme je les dis j'ai visité
quelques autobus et dans certains à un
ou deux passagers n'avaient pas de
masque nous les avons donc sortis des
véhicules à partir d'aujourd'hui le port
du masque est obligatoire à travers le
pays
j'ai donc ajuster le dossier du siège en
conséquence je transporte de passagers à
l'arrière et je demande aux passagers de
porter un masque pour monter dans le
taxi
à mon avis ces ordres aurait dû être
donnée plus tôt il aurait dû rendre
obligatoire le port du masque afin que
nous ne perdions pas nos chers
compatriotes dans ces circonstances
difficiles à voir un masque est devenu
obligatoire à partir de maintenant
cela signifie pour moi que quiconque qui
ne porte pas de masque ne favorise pas
sa santé et celle de ses compatriotes
j'ai fait une erreur car je ne le porte
pas cela est vraiment une action
opportune parce que ne pas porter un
masque nous incite à propager le virus
et à le transmettre à beaucoup de gens
ou à être infecté nous-mêmes ne pas
porter un masque est une trahison pour
omar nasir ali sociologue franco
iranienne enseignante à sciences po les
autorités iraniennes ne sont pas
transparents dans leur gestion des
crises l'état a décidé de ne pas
dévoiler le chiffre exact des morts et
des victimes
alors dans cette situation quand il ya
une décision étatique comme quoi il faut
pas être dévoilé le chiffre exact vous
pouvez imaginer à quel point on est dans
la confusion
on ne sait pas très bien ce qui se passe
ce qu'on a pu comprendre est extrêmement
alarmants dans le sens où on est en face
d'un cas médicalement atypique dans le
sens où les victimes pour la plupart
sont très très jeune l'iran est le seul
pays pour l'instant où les morts de
coronavirus pourcentage et le régiment
de 30 ans donc une population entre 20
et 30 ans les victimes de covile 19
donc c'est pas le cas atypique et sachez
que l'inde est désormais le troisième
pays du monde le plus touché par locaux
vides 19 derrière les états unis et le
brésil le pays reconnaissent et d'un
étang une explosion du nombre de
contaminations près de sept cent mille
personnes ont été testées positives dans
le pays clément hospital
à l'entrée de ce marché aux légumes de
new delhi un employé prend
systématiquement la température de
chaque client venu faire ses courses
les gestes barrières et les mesures
sanitaires semblent être respectée dans
ce quartier de la capitale indienne
pourtant le ministère de la santé a
rapporté une nouvelle hausse quotidienne
alarmante par rapport à ces dernières
semaines le virus circule en effet
rapidement dans les villes très
densément peuplés dont new delhi nous
avons peur mais nous devons quand même
surmonté ce réflexe chacun dans le monde
craint pour sa vie mais c'est aussi
nécessaire de travailler
la sensibilisation est nécessaire elle
permettrait de contrôler la propagation
du virus
le gouvernement craint qu'un demi
million de personnes ne soient
contaminés d'ici la fin du mois de
juillet certains états du sous continent
indien en pleine phase de déconfinement
envisage de prolonger des mesures
strictes dans certaines villes du pays
ici à bombay des personnels de santé
font du porte à porte à la recherche de
personnes présentant des symptômes du
virus
nous déterminons si quelqu'un est
susceptible d'être contaminées ou non
c'est ce que nous faisons nous vérifions
leur température avec notre thermomètre
électronique et leur capacité
respiratoire avec la troc si m les
mesures de confinement instauré en inde
depuis fin mars ont été progressivement
levées les écoles métro cinémas et
salles de sport reste cependant ferme et
les vols internationaux sont toujours
cloués au sol le premier ministre
narendra modi a déclaré la semaine
dernière que le taux de mortalité était
sous contrôle mais que le pays traverse
est toujours un moment critique
d'après un businessman et si le prochain
locataire de la maison blanche et est un
rappeur l'artiste américain kanye west
annoncé hier vouloir briguer la
présidence des états unis en novembre
prochain
malgré ses faibles chances d'y arriver
cette candidature peut-elle changer la
donne
éléments de réponse avec estelle farges
un duel donald trump versus joe biden
jusqu'à présent la course à la maison
blanche se limitait à une confrontation
entre ces deux hommes
mais le 4 juillet dernier en tweets a
quelque peu perturbé le cours de la
campagne présidentielle américaine un
tweet signé kanye west nous devons
maintenant accomplir la promesse de
l'amérique en ayant confiance en dieu en
unifiant nos visions et en construisant
notre avenir
je suis candidat à la présidence des
états unis pour le moment le rappeur
hommes d'affaires et milliardaire de 43
ans n'a pas fourni davantage de détails
sur ses intentions
impossible donc de savoir s'il s'agit
d'une plaisanterie ou d'une réelle
ambition toujours est il que kanye west
a déjà reçu quelques soutiens et
notamment celui d'ellen masquer le
patron de tesla au 36 millions d'abonnés
sur twitter
mais dans les rues de new york les
réactions sont beaucoup plus mitigées
c'est de la folie c'est une idée folle
je veux dire ce pays est déjà foutu pour
commencer a ajouté cela cette idée et
nous serons complètement perdu je pense
que c'est une super idée parce que je
pense qu'il est temps pour les états
unis de se débarrasser de trump nous
sommes fatigués de lui nous ne voulons
pas de trump pour président vous ne
pouvez pas donner un président en
seulement quatre ans pour diriger un
pays il a besoin de plus et tout ça pour
vous dire que je donne un peu ma faveur
à trump en le traitant correctement il a
besoin de quatre ans supplémentaires
pour voir ce qu'il pourrait faire c'est
un bon type et ce n'est pas la première
fois que l'artiste évoque cette ambition
présidentielle en 2015 à la cérémonie
des mtv
et awards kanye west avait déjà 2020 en
tête et puis plus récemment en 2010 neuf
lors d'une interview dans beats one show
une émission d'appels musique l'homme
avait affirmé qu'il serait un jour à la
tête du pays
il viendra un temps où je serai le
président des états unis et je me
souviendrai de tout fondateur qui n'aura
pas été capables de comprendre
culturellement ce que nous faisons il
s'agit d'idées et mon frère de nouvelles
idées des gens avec des idées des gens
qui croient à la vérité et oui comme
vous l'avez probablement deviné à ce
moment là j'ai décidé en 2020 de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
on peut aussi citer l'une des paroles de
son titre fact en 2020 je gagnerai
l'élection une candidature qui selon
certains analystes n'apportera rien
d'autre qu'une division des votes côté
démocrate
qu'est-ce qu'a kanye west à nous offrir
rien il ne proposera rien de plus
tout ce qu'il fera c'est diviser les
votes des démocrates les gens côté
conservateurs républicains eux ne
voteront pas pour kanye west il pourrait
peut-être attirer les voix des jeunes
mais ce vote jeunes n'a jamais à mon
avis et n'aura jamais sans doute une
grande influence sur les élections
ce dans mon groupe d'âge des 40 ans et
plus n'iront pas voter pour kanye west
et ses dix sans animosité envers lui
c'est juste leur regard sur ce qu'il
pourra réellement accomplir mais kanye
west peut-il réellement devenir le 46e
président des états unis peu probable
premièrement parce qu'ils ne possèdent
l'investiture d'aucun parti il faudrait
donc il se présente en candidat
indépendant
l'histoire des états unis nous a montré
qu'un candidat ni républicain ni
démocrate n'avait aucune chance
d'accéder à la victoire
et puis deuxièmement le temps presse
l'élection et dans quatre mois ce qui
laisse peu de marge aux rappeurs pour
remplir toutes les formalités
administratives afin d'entrer dans la
course si 2020 semble quasiment joué
pour kanye west l'artiste pourrait
reporter son ambition à 2024 l'homme a
toujours affiché son soutien à donald
trump et il n'est pas impossible qu'ils
entendent briguer l'investiture
républicaine dans avec quatre ans autre
interrogation et si cette candidature
cash est plutôt un bon coup de com
l'artiste a en effet sorti le 30 juin
dernier soit quatre jours
avant son tweet un single qui annonce
l'arrivée de son nouvel album god
scontri la question mérite d'être posée
la france accueille tel sur son sol des
militaires saoudiens enfin qu'il se
forme c'est ce qu'affirme amnesty
international dans une enquête elle
publié ces derniers jours un ancien site
militaire de la meuse servirait de base
d'entraînement pour des soldats du
royaume wahhabite
une situation qui interroge alors que la
guerre au yémen se poursuit thomas bonne
et l'implication présumée de la france
dans la guerre au yémen est souvent
pointée du doigt par des ong voire même
par l'onu qui a épinglé en septembre
dernier le soutien logistique de
certains pays dont la france à la
coalition qui mène la guerre contre les
outils au yémen ces nouvelles
révélations d'amnesty international
risquent de renforcer ces accusations
après plusieurs mois d'enquêté l'omg
publie des informations sur la création
d'un centre d'entraînement dans la
commune de commercy dans la meuse un
campus
implanté sur une ancienne base militaire
et qui appartient au groupe belge s'est
mis l'objectif recevoir et former les
clients de l'entreprise en l'occurrence
des militaires saoudiens pour apprendre
la manipulation de tourelles canon
cockerill au programme instructions des
tireurs des pilotes et des mécaniciens
au maniement de sa tourelle et de son
système d'armes d'une capacité de 120
stagiaires le campus cockerill doit
accueillir ses soldats à partir de 2017
et pour sept ans - une formation censée
s'étaler chaque année sur six à neuf
mois dans la paisible campagne française
hôtels restaurants sauna et mosquées
pour créer une sorte de bulle tout a été
pensé pour placer les militaires
saoudiens dans les meilleures conditions
il est très difficile de savoir si le
campus en a déjà accueilli
écoutez ce qu'en dit audrey lebel
l'auteur de l'article
en off on me dit qu'il y en a qui y en a
même qui aurait été coincés là bas
pendant toute la crise du coc vide mais
officiellement même les élus locaux
disent ne pas savoir si les formations
ont véritablement commencé à commercy si
la présence des soldats saoudiens
à confirmer l'existence même de ce
campus et de ce programme d'entraînement
font débat car au delà de la situation
géopolitique
ce projet a bénéficié d'argent public
notamment par le biais des aides
accordées par le conseil régional de
lorraine
six cent mille euros avait ainsi été
débloqués en 2015 provoquant de vives
réactions notamment de jacqueline
fontaine qui était à l'époque conseiller
régional e élevé il y a un grand
décalage entre la présentation bien
pudique du dossier et la réalité du
projet on apprend à faire la guerre à
des saoudiens
on n'est pas sûr qu'on ne les retrouvera
pas un jour face à nous sur un terrain
quelconque
surtout que pour justifier un tel
investissement les retombées économiques
étaient mises en avant retombées dont
les habitants peinent à voir les fruits
encore aujourd'hui plus globalement
cette base d'entraînement pose la
question du soutien de la france à la
coalition saoudienne et émirati au yémen
la secrétaire d'état aux armes et
geneviève darrieussecq s'est d'ailleurs
rendu sur le campus de commercy en avril
bien que sous pavillon privé ce centre
semble finalement s'inscrire dans une
volonté exprimée en 2015 par le quai
d'orsay de vouloir encourager je cite
l'augmentation de la coopération sur le
terrain des exercices militaires et de
l'entraînement en arabie saoudite et en
france depuis le monde a pu constater
l'horreur humanitaire créée par cette
guerre au yémen et l'indignation de
l'opinion publique suscite un certain
embarras parmi les gouvernants des pays
exportateurs d'armes en arabie saoudite
cette base d'entraînement sur le sol
français pourrait là encore être une
épine dans le pied du ministère des
armées et a fortiori pour le président
de la république
pékin appelle paris à garantir un
environnement équitable pour les
entreprises chinoises la france souhaite
en effet restreint fortement l'accès de
huawei au marché français de la 5g des
annonces sur fond de tensions
diplomatiques entre washington et pékin
et les précisions de clément hospital
l'avenir du géant chinois huawei sur le
marché de la 5g en france s'annonce très
incertain l' agence nationale de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information
l'ansi annoncé qu'elle limiterait ses
licences d'exploitation à une durée
allant de trois à huit ans ces
restrictions concernerait les opérateurs
français comme sfr ou bouygues telecom
qui utiliserait les équipements de
huawei pour déployer l'internet mobile
de cinquième génération
il n'y aura pas un bannissement total
les opérateurs qui n'utilisent pas
ouailles nous les incitons à ne pas y
aller car c'est un peu le sens naturel
des choses
nous ne sommes pas dans du why bashing
ni dans du racisme anti chinois ou
disons juste que le risque n'est pas le
même avec des équipementiers européens
qu'avec des non européens
il ne faut pas se mentir après cette
décision défavorable au géant chinois
des télécommunications la diplomatie
chinoise et mais l'espoir de voir la
france
garantir un environnement équitable à
ces entreprises
enfin la chine espère que la partie
française pour observer une attitude
objective et juste respecter les lois du
marché et la volonté des entreprises en
les laissant faire leur choix de façon
indépendante et dans leur propre intérêt
et adopter des mesures concrètes pour
mettre en place un environnement ouvert
équitable et non discriminatoire pour
les entreprises de tous les pays y
compris les entreprises chinoises fait
une chambre a nié huawei numéro deux
mondial de la téléphonie et surtout
leader des équipements 5 g le groupe est
depuis plusieurs années scrutées par les
états unis qui affirme le soupçonné
d'espionnage au profit de pékin
washington fait donc pression sur ses
alliés pour qu'ils bannissent huawei
pour raisons de sécurité
mais certains observateurs estiment
qu'il s'agit surtout pour washington de
protéger les champions américains
du secteur fragilisé par leur retard
technologique sur la 5g en europe le
royaume-uni devrait annoncer ce mois-ci
des dispositions imposant le retrait
progressif des équipements mois où elle
du réseau 5g du pays
ouais c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité de vos matin 7 heures du
matin heure française excellente fin de
soirée à tous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous de
cecco politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
comme on le sait donner un look pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
l'huile de palme est l'un des produits
les plus controversées de notre temps
c'est une graisse végétale solide et
elle est très bon marché en 2010 est la
production a atteint un sommet de 63
millions de tonnes cette croissance
rapide de la demande globale d'huile peu
coûteuse à cause d une expansion massive
des plantations de palmiers à huile
ce qui entraîne à son tour la
destruction de la forêt tropicale
dans la seule indonésie plus de dix
millions d'hectares de forêts primaires
ont été détruits et cela se poursuit
[Musique]
comme on bat les deux n'englobent pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver pensé que
ça allait me rendre plus tolérante et ça
m'a rendu plus intolérant alors pour
elle c'était d'expression je voudrais
vous poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde d'avant
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui prend de la
hauteur jusque sur les toits de pâles
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons parler
des aides des aides aux grandes
entreprises
bonjour thomas bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
c'est cash alors depuis le confinement
on sait l'impact économique va être
considérable les indicateurs sont au
rouge à l'heure face à tous ces vents
contraires et pour éviter d'éventuelles
faillites ou dépôt de bilan
l'état abreuve certains secteurs dead en
tout genre et pourtant des plans sociaux
sont parfois annoncé dans des
entreprises qui perçoivent ces mêmes
aides on va donc passer en revue ses
différents dispositifs
nous on commence avec le traditionnel
tiroirs cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
on le sait l'état n'a pas lésiné sur les
aides à apporter aux entreprises pour
faire face à la crise lié ou covic 19
pourtant quelques unes sortent un peu du
lot disons qu'elles ont reçu un peu plus
quoi 7 milliards pour air france et 5
couronneau débloqués en urgence au plus
fort de la crise en avril
l'état étant actionnaire de ces
entreprises à 15% pour le constructeur
autour et 14 pour la compagnie aérienne
z sous forme de prêts garantis par
l'état que air france et renault
s'engage et évidemment à rembourser sauf
s'ils finissent en redressement
judiciaire là bas ce sera à l'état de
payer la note
anouk quoi nos impôts ces prêts sont
évidemment sous conditions pas folle la
guêpe pour renault s'engager dans
l'airbus de la batterie un énorme projet
de création d'un géant européen de
batteries pour voitures électriques et
pour air france des objectifs de
rentabilité et de baisse des émissions
de co2 à mais rien sur la sauvegarde des
emplois
ah ben non malgré ces milliards mis sur
la table par l'état les entreprises ont
déjà enclenché des plans sociaux pour
renault la suppression de 15000 emplois
dans le monde dont 4600 en france pour
air france un plan de départs
volontaires qui concernerait autour de
huy 1300 salariés autres grands fleurons
français pourfendeur d'emplois airbus
qui malgré un plan de 15 me
pour l'aéronautique va mettre saint nic
de ses employés français au chômage
olivier on l'a vu dans le tiroir cash
d'antoine mahsas des aides de l'état
pour des entreprises en difficulté un
mot assez rapide sur sur scène sur ces
aides on va évidemment les détails et
dans la deuxième partie cette émission
alors ces aides c'est pas de l'argent
frais c'est d'abord et avant tout des
garanties de dette dès qu'il faudra un
moment rembourser et malheureusement
comme ce sont des entreprises qui
brassent on je dirais en fête permanente
pour air france pour renault il on line
gagne jamais d'argent ont finalement
c'est renault s'était nissan qui gagner
de l'argent mais vu les problèmes de
carlos ghosn il ya une espèce de
scission si vous voulez entre entre
nissan et renault et je pense que le
grand groupe intégré dont rêvait carlos
ghosn maintenant est terminée et donc
voilà on essaie d'entretenir un groupe
qui est mort en le landais temps encore
un petit peu plus est avec des
contreparties qu'ils sont qui sont
ridicules puisque on vous dit il faut
qu'ils rapatrient 2 2
de l'industrie en france sauf qu'il
gagnait pas d'argent quand c'était dans
des pays à bas coûts ils vont en gagner
encore moins quand ça sera en france et
donc il faut réellement se poser la
question plutôt que à fonds perdus de
mettre des milliards et de s'apercevoir
dans trois ou quatre ans que ça n'a
servi à rien et qu'il faudra à ce
moment-là licencier tout le monde donc
il faut vraiment se poser des questions
sur une vraie politique industrielle
faire des choix et puis au lieu de
dépenser des milliards comme ça pour
rien il faudrait mieux les dépensés pour
former les gens et les replacer ailleurs
on va passer la deuxième partie de
l'émission y vient on reçoit aujourd'hui
dans les langues économiste maître de
conférences en économie à l'université
paris xiii bonjour dany langue merci
d'être avec nous dans cette émission de
ses caches on va passer en revue donc
les différents dispositifs d'aidé mis en
place par l'état mais d'abord quelques
indicateurs économiques qui sont donnés
par le gouvernement avec la récession
économique en france
elle devrait atteindre 11% du pib en
2020 le déficit de la france pourrait
culminer à 11 4% et puis la dette
publique de notre pays 120,9 % du pib
des indicateurs très préoccupant et qui
ont donc entraîner des aides massives de
l'état d'un élan que je voulais d'abord
avoir votre avis sur ces dispositifs
dead qui ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement ces dernières semaines
alors déjà il faut dire que ces
dispositifs dead était nécessaire les
pays qui n'ont pas fait ça vont se
trouver dans une récession encore pire
alors le moindre souci avec ces
dispositifs c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément bénéficié à celles et ceux qui
étaient censés en bénéficier et en
particulier les pme et les pmi quand on
discutait avec des patrons pme pmi
ils sont assez nombreux ils sont pas
unanimes ils sont assez nombreux à vous
dire qu'ils n'ont pas eu la teneur
moi je pense qu'il faut pas paniqué en
voyant ces indicateurs il ya une grande
partie de cette dette publique est
détenue par la banque centrale
tant que la banque centrale les gars
dans bilan il ya aucun problème de ce
côté-là je pense que c'était nécessaire
ma crainte serait plutôt que maintenant
on est un retournement complet de
politique économique et qu'on se met à
faire de l'austérité ou prétexte de c2c
chicha et ça ce serait extrêmement
dangereux parce que ça nous mettrait
dans une situation encore pire que celle
dans laquelle on est aidé en tableaux
mois ce qui serait assez intéressant et
qu'on oublie souvent de mentionner c'est
de regarder où en est la dette privée
parce qu'on a quand même un quart des
entreprises françaises qui risque de
déposer le bilan à la suite du cornât
virus donc ça va ça risque de poser des
problèmes bancaires et ça risque de
causer des panique sur les marchés
financiers
donc à mon avis il faudrait aussi
présenté chiffres si on veut présenter
un tableau complet
donc à mon sens la récession grave donc
elles appellent des mesures
exceptionnelles
c'est le moment ou jamais de repenser à
des mesures keynésiennes donc les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
était des dispositifs d'urgence
maintenant à mon sens il faut mettre en
place des dispositifs qui soit beaucoup
plus durable qu'ils soient beaucoup plus
soutenable et qu'ils soient orientés
vers des investissements publics massifs
pour faire repartir l'économie mais
aussi pour assurer la nécessaire
transition écologique
alors parmi les dispositifs dead qui ont
été mises en place par l'état il ya
notamment les pge les prêts garantis par
l'état qui sont destinés aux entreprises
qui peuvent représenter jusqu'au quart
de leur chiffre d'affaires de 2019 ils
sont garantis à hauteur de 70 à 90% par
l'état et l'enveloppent prévu est autour
de 300 milliards d'euros et parmi les
bénéficiaires il ya le secteur de la
construction qui représente un quart des
sommes garanties suivi de l'industrie
manufacturière
olivier qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
dispositif de ce moyen d'aider les
entreprises par des prêts dont l'état se
porte garant mais c'est pas un moyen
d'aider les entreprises
c'est un moyen de les endettés et donc
en fait quelque part de l'est de les
acheter
je vous avais dit à quelques il ya
quelques semaines on était en rentrer
dans une période de deux sociétés
isation de l'économie c'est à ça qu'on
assiste c'est à dire que on endette des
entreprises qui sont déjà pour la
plupart déjà pas mal endettés et quand
vous êtes endettés et quand vous êtes
surendetté en plus vous appartenez à qui
vous appartenez à votre créancier donc
fin de l'histoire
et comme c'est l'état oubliez le le
créancier au final puisqu'il garantit
ses prêts eh bien vous appartenait à
l'état l'entreprise dont l'état est déjà
actionnaire et qui sont parfois si ce
n'est des fleurons en tout cas des
entreprises importantes pour la france
on pense à air france à airbus on va
évidemment revenir sur ces entreprises
est ce qu'il est nécessaire quand même
que l'état vienne en aide à ses
entreprises
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
olivier delamarche le moi ce qui
m'inquiète vraiment ces niveaux
d'endettement privé et donc on contribue
se faisant alors nettement prisé et pour
un certain nombre d'entreprises ça peut
justifier le est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de pme qui n'ont pas eu accès aux
prêts garantis par l'état parce que
quand faut-il rappeler que ça passe par
les banques et que les banques
commencent à sentir le vent du boulet et
donc il ya un certain nombre d'entre eux
puissent y eut même solvables qui n'ont
pas eu accès à ces crèches donc pour moi
c'est pas du tout ceux des tees à sion
d'économie c'est pas ça dont il est
question et certainement pas avec le
gouvernement p nous avons mais par
contre j'suis d'accord avec olivier
delamarche pour dire que le niveau de
dette privée est inquiétant ne s'était
pas forcément un endettement
supplémentaire dont on avait besoin
alors on l'a vu en première partie de
cette émission le problème qui se pose
avec certains de ses plans dead et bien
c'est qu'il coïncide aussi avec des
plans de restructuration va prendre
l'exemple d'air france pour commencer
7 milliards d'euros des dons ont été
apportées 4 milliard de prêts bancaires
garantis et 3 milliards de prêts directs
pour air france klm les pays-bas
promettre une aide de 3 4 milliards
d'euros pour soutenir la compagnie
nationale et puis donc le plan de
reconstruction d'air france klm 7500
suppressions de postes était envisagée
d'ici fin 2022 6560 des 41 mille
salariés au sein de la compagnie dont
bill pardon au sein de la compagnie